avant que la vidéo ne commence j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont il parle bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent et à développer rapidement
et facilement leur culture générale
parce que leur rapport au savoir a
changé et une fois qu'ils les appliquent
les cinq secrets ils comprennent toutes
les références des personnes cultivées
ils savent s'exprimer avec profondeur
sur n'importe quel sujet ils brillent
par leur culture dans les conversations
c'est dans les débats et ils ont le
recul nécessaire pour faire preuve
d'esprit critique ça vous intéresse et
bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets et
je vous explique comment les appliquer
dès aujourd'hui pour vous cultivez 10
fois plus rapidement sans vous prendre
la tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
soit tant qu'ils ont sur celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo c'est
l'histoire de 10 secondes donc faites le
maintenant et vous pourrez découvrir le
premier secret qui vous attendra bien au
chaud dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voila voila je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire je
vous laisse regarder la vidéo et moi je
vais promener aristote
[Musique]
première référence la richesse des
nations adam smith ma liste commence
avec la richesse des nations le titre
abrégé d' enquête sur la nature et les
causes de la richesse des nations ma
liste commence avec ce titre parce que
c'est comme vous le savez peut-être le
premier livre moderne d'économies il a
été publié en 1776 et son auteur
l'écossé adam smith passe pour le père
de l'économie même si tous les
économistes ne sont pas d'accord sur ce
point il a ce statut parce qu'il a
inspirés les économistes des décennies
suivantes qui prétendront offert de
l'économie une science c'est à dire une
discipline intellectuelle qui produit un
savoir fiable après les économistes
professionnels de leur propre aveu ne
lis pas le chef-d'oeuvre du père de
l'économie il y a même une blague
d'économistes qui dit l'économiste qui a
lu la richesse des nations n'est pas
encore né pour avoir essayé de le lire
je confirme qu'il ya un problème je l'
ai commencé quand j'étais en école de
commerce mais j'ai arrêté au bout de 2
300 pages sur plus de 500 pour le
premier tome est presque 1200 en tout
j'ai arrêté étant l'expression est
lourde même parfois maladroite mal
structurées sans méthode et puis les
répétitions et les interminables
digressions sont vraiment fatigante la
description d'amazones dit pudiquement
que lire la richesse des nations en
entier je cite relève de la gageure
c'est à dire que c'est un défi vous et a
échoué et elle va même jusqu'à assurer
le lecteur qu'il retrouvera bien les
textes de référence dans l'ouvragé en
entier en gros elle lui dit seuls 10% du
bouquin sont lisibles ce n'est pas la
peine d'essayer de lire le reste
kembs lui dit qu'il a lu la richesse des
nations en entier pendant une croisière
et qu'il l'a bien aimé mais je n'ai pas
trouvé plus de détails et puis je me
demande comment il l'a lu voilà pour la
forme je passe au fond quelles sont les
idées essentielles de la richesse des
nations trois grandes idées sont
importantes pour votre culture générale
première grande idée
l'économie fonctionne grâce à l'égoïsme
c'est l'intérêt personnel c'est à dire
ce qui est objectivement avantageux à un
individu qui motive son effort et non
pas l'altruisme par conséquent le
producteur ne satisfait pas le
consommateur par bonté d'âme mais parce
que son succès en dépend la quête
égoïste du profit a donc un effet
altruiste elle garantit la qualité des
biens et des services c'est cette
première grande idée qui illustre la
célèbre formule à propos du boucher du
marchand de bière et du boulanger je
cite smith
ce n'est pas de la bienveillance du
boucher du marchand de bière et du
boulanger que nous attendons notre dîner
mais bien du soin qu'ils apportent à
leurs intérêts autrement dit pour
trouver du bon pain il faut miser sur le
fait que le boulanger et veut gagner de
l'argent pas sur le fait qu'il nous aime
bien
deuxième grande idée une main invisible
harmonise l'économie je vous cite le
célèbre passage de la richesse des
nations le chef d'entreprise est conduit
par une main invisible à remplir une fin
qui n'entre nullement dans ses
intentions mais ce n'est pas toujours ce
qu'il y a de plus mal pour la société
que cette fin entre eux pour rien dans
ses intentions cette célèbre métaphore
signifie que l'effet altruiste des
égoïsmes individuels réguler
efficacement les relations économiques
et sociales il existe plus précisément
ce qu'on appelle une identité naturelle
des intérêts à chaque intérêt individuel
en correspond à un autre de telle sorte
que l'interaction économique produit un
bénéfice mutuel pour le dire plus
simplement chaque individu qui poursuit
son intérêt égoïste peut être utile à
d'autres individus donc si nous sommes
tous égoïstes nous pouvons tous être
utiles les uns aux autres la société
fonctionne correctement comme cela parce
que chaque individu a intérêt à
travailler à satisfaire les besoins
d'autres individus
cette vision de la société contenus dans
la métaphore de la main invisible
signifie que c'est le marché le lieu
naturel d'organisation des échanges qui
assurent l'ordre social en effet c'est
le marché qui nous permet de découvrir
comment nous pouvons nous être utile à
autrui
l'état ne doit donc perturbé le
fonctionnement du marché pour smith son
rôle se limite à la défense à la
protection des citoyens et à la
production d'infrastructures
troisième grande idée de la richesse des
nations la spécialisation décuple la
productivité adam smith décrit dans la
richesse des nations comment dans une
usine d'épingler la division du travail
des ouvriers permet d'accroître la
production cette idée révèle le rôle de
l'intelligence humaine dans la
croissance par le biais de
l'organisation du travail en vue de
décupler la productivité est tendue au
niveau international la division du
travail prouve la supériorité du libre
échange un pays a intérêt à se
concentrer sur les biens qu'il est
capable de produire à un coût inférieur
par rapport aux autres pays c'est ce
qu'on appelle à la théorie de
l'avantagent absolue on n'illustre
souvent cette théorie en disant que
l'angleterre de l'époque devraient
produire exclusivement des draps et le
portugal du vin plutôt que chaque pays
essaie de produire les deux bien en même
temps d'après la théorie de l'avantagent
absolue si toutes les nations suivent la
même logique alors elles seront toutes
gagnantes
voilà pour les trois grandes idées de la
richesse des nations ce livre est une
référence incontournable en économie
parce qu adam smith y érige la liberté
économique la concurrence et le marché
en concepts fondateurs du capitalisme la
nuance qu'on peut apporter c'est que ces
idées étaient déjà dans l'air à l'époque
sachez également que la métaphore de la
main invisible qui deviendra un concept
majeur en économie et bien cette
métaphore n'apparaît qu'une seule fois
en tout dans la richesse des nations ce
qui signifie que ce sont les lecteurs
qui en ont fait un concept majeur de
l'économie
deuxième référence et c'est sur le
principe de population thomas malthus
cette référence est important son
économie parce que c'est la première
réflexion importante à propos de
l'impact de la démographie sur la
prospérité l'idée fondamentale c'est que
la population croît trop vite par
rapport aux ressources le principal
problème qui guette l'économie c'est
donc la surpopulation
l'essai sur le principe de population a
toujours été controversé
parce que la perspective de contenir
voire de réduire la population n'est pas
plaisante on a l'impression qu'en
empêchant des naissances on tue des
êtres humains quelque part dans le
détail la thèse de malthus adhérents
j'ai pas mal de monde elle est contraire
aux commandements divins de la genèse
croissez et multipliez alors même que
malthus était pasteur elle est contraire
à l'idée politique et géopolitique
conventionnelles selon laquelle la
puissance d'un pays dépend de la taille
de sa population c'est important pour
faire la guerre avec beaucoup de soldats
par exemple et enfin elle choque aussi
les socialistes qui soupçonne malthus et
plus tard les élites capitalistes
malthusienne de vouloir se débarrasser
des masses pauvres qui encombrent la
société bref malthus ne s'est pas fait
que des amis avec ce livre voici ce
qu'on dira proudhon le plus célèbre
socialiste français quelques dizaines
d'années plus tard la théorie de malthus
c'est la théorie de l'assassinât
politique de l'assassinât par
philanthropie par amour de dieu on
retrouve ce que j'ai mentionné au départ
le rapprochement entre la maîtrise de la
démographie et le meurtre pour
comprendre d'où vient la théorie
économique de laisser sur le principe de
population il faut la replacer dans son
contexte historique
le premier élément important de ce
contexte c'est la naissance de la grande
industrie en angleterre les richesses
croise mais le nombre de pauvres et les
inégalités croise tout autant du coup
des gens imaginent des plans de réforme
pour résoudre ce problème et c'est là
qu'intervient le second élément
important du contexte la révolution
française cet événement inspire aux
réformateurs anglais l'idée qu'il faut
carrément supprimer les gouvernements
pour résoudre le problème de la misère
c'est notamment la conviction de
l'écrivain auquel veut répondre malthus
william godwin qui passe aujourd'hui
pour un précurseur de l'anarchisme je
précise william godwin n'a rien à voir
avec le point godwin
ainsi laissé sur le principe de
population et publiée comme un pamphlet
anti socialiste c'est une arme
intellectuelle pour répondre aux
révolutionnaires qui veulent renverser
les institutions car malthus démontre
l'inutilité
réformes politiques et sociales pour
guérir les maux de la société c'est pour
ça que les conservateurs de l'époque
accueille le livre avec enthousiasme et
que leurs adversaires le honnissent
voilà pour le contexte qu'en dire sur la
forme maintenant comme ce livre est au
départ un pamphlet écrit par un écrivain
relativement jeune malthus à 32 ans à
l'époque le style ne ressemble pas à
celui d'une oeuvre de science le ton et
polémiques et il ya de l'emphase dans
l'expression si cette dimension rend le
propos plutôt agréable à lire je n'ai
pour ma part pas réussi à aller au bout
quand j'ai ouvert le premier tome il ya
une dizaine d'années les analyses des
statistiques démographiques ne m'avait
pas passionné et puis il y en a quand
même pour près de 1000 pages
maintenant que retenir de laisser sur le
principe de population sur le fond
l'idée essentielle et comme je voulais
dit au début que la démographie
conditionne la prospérité les humains
tendent tous les êtres vivants à
développer leur espèce au delà de ce que
permettent les ressources disponibles
sur le plan mathématique la production
des ressources augmentent de manière
incrémentale 1 2 3 4 5 etc tandis que
les individus se reproduisent de manière
proportionnée 1 2 4 8 16 etc vous l'avez
compris ça va beaucoup plus vite
malthus en déduit qu'il existe
naturellement un écart grandissant de
façon exponentielle entre le niveau de
la population d'une part et le niveau
des ressources alimentaires d'autre part
et apporter de l'aide aux pauvres ne
fait qu'aggraver le problème
malthus accuse les lois sur les pauvres
en anglais pour l'os de l'angleterre de
son époque de nourrir un cercle vicieux
en améliorant le bien-être des pauvres
elles font croître leur population donc
le nombre de pauvres qui ont besoin d'un
emploi donc le chômage et ce faisant
elle creuse paradoxalement encore
davantage la pauvreté la bonne solution
c'est de préserver la proportion entre
la population et les ressources soit par
les obstacles privatif comme le mariage
tardif où la contraception
soit par les obstacles destructif telle
la maladie la misère la guerre etc
malthus précise que les deux types
d'obstacles doivent être combinées en
proportion inverse par exemple les pays
très salubre ou la maladie ne limite pas
la population ces pays ont intérêt à
développer le sentiment de
responsabilité individuelle de leur site
web la théorie de malthus et plus
particulièrement l'idée de la nécessaire
proportion entre la population et les
ressources ses idées reviennent à la
mode depuis la fin des trente glorieuses
dans l'écologie par exemple le
biologiste américain paul r ehrlich qui
est prof à l'université de standford
polaire ehrlich avait suscité la
controverse avec son livre the
population bomb paru en 1968 en prônant
la limitation des naissances afin que le
niveau de la population correspondent au
niveau des ressources disponibles il
estimait encore au milieu d année 2010
que l'humanité ferait bien de revenir à
1,5 milliard d'individus soit moins de
20% de la population mondiale actuelle
je dis cela en octobre 2021
troisième référence traité d'économie
politique jean baptiste 7 cette
référence est importante en économie
parce qu'elle énonce certaines des idées
fondamentales de la théorie classique on
y trouve notamment la fameuse loi de say
dont je vais vous parler loi qui servira
de référence aux économistes du 19e
siècle avant d'être remises en cause le
siècle suivant par keynes cette
influence théorique fait de jean
baptiste c'est le plus grand économiste
français de l'ère classique voire le
plus grand économiste français tout
court mais c'est bien sur ce sujet à
débat
son traité d'économie politique est
tirée des articles d'économies qu'il
avait rédigés pour le journal qu'il
avait lui même fondé à son retour à
paris en 1794 à la fin de la terreur ce
traité a connu un succès considérable au
point d'être traduits dans 10 pays
ce succès tient probablement en partie à
la clarté du propos comme la matière du
traité est issu d'articles de journaux
ce n'est pas étonnant si les
journalistes écrivait comme les
théoriciens de l'économie personne ne
lirai les journaux
donc le style de jean baptiste say est
accessible même pour nous qui le lisons
deux cents ans plus tard chaque chapitre
du traité d'économie politique
correspond grosso modo en termes de
longueur à un article et chaque chapitre
est subdivisé en une multitude de
paragraphe certains paragraphes se
résumant même à une seule et unique
phrase j'en ai déjà parlé dans d'autres
vidéos la subdivision en paragraphes
avec idéalement une idée par paragraphe
cette manière de faire facilite vraiment
la lecture en outre ses écrits avec les
mots de la langue ordinaire il n'y a pas
de jargon et il prend soin de définir
clairement les concepts qui l'utilisent
encore une fois avec ses qualités il
n'est pas étonnant que le livre se soit
si bien vendu ce qui est drôle c'est que
ricardo le fondateur de la théorie
classique ricardo reprochera cette
grande clarté à cei parce qu'il estime
que ça dévalorise le travail des
économistes c'est sûr que le contenu du
traité d'économie politique ressemble
plus à de la vulgarisation qui a une
théorie scientifique mais pour celles
économiques ont appelé à l'époque
économie politique pour lui l'économie
est un savoir pratiques qui permettent à
la société industrielle de surmonter ses
crises c'est même un savoir d'intérêt
général c'est pourquoi il faut le
démocratiser et le diffuser au maximum
dans le corps social c'est-à-dire le
vulgariser ce n était pas un pur
intellectuelle un rat de bibliothèque
au contraire il a fait beaucoup de
choses dans sa vie il a participé à la
révolution française il s'est impliqué
en politique lors de l'accession au
pouvoir de napoléon bonaparte il a
encore été journaliste entrepreneurs
dans l'industrie du coton émissaires du
gouvernement
il a créé la première école de commerce
de l'histoire le scp dont je suis
diplômé et il a même été nommé peu de
temps avant sa mort au collège de france
où il a occupé la première chaire
d'économie politique bref jean baptiste
say était un homme d'action il ne vivait
pas dans le ciel des idées ce qui est
probablement mieux pour parler
d'économie je passe maintenant au fond
qu'est ce qui est essentiel pour votre
culture générale dans le traité
d'économie politique en premier lieu
j'aime bien la définition de l'économie
que cède dans le discours préliminaire
c'est à dire la préface du traité je le
cite on a longtemps confondu la
politique proprement dit la science de
l'organisation des sociétés avec
l'économie politique qui enseignent
comment se forment se distribuent et se
consomme à les richesses qui satisfont
aux besoins des sociétés
l'économie qu'on appelait à l'époque
économie politique encore une fois
l'économie c'est donc pour c'est la
science de la production de la
distribution et de la consommation des
richesses
c'est pour cette raison qu'il divise le
traité en trois livres le premier est
consacré à la production des richesses
le deuxième à la distribution et le
troisième à la consommation en second
lieu le traité a donné à la théorie
classique deux idées importantes
premières grandes idées
jean-baptiste-say affirme dans le
chapitre 15 que c'est l'offre qui crée
la demande c'est à dire que c'est la
production de biens et services qui
engendre les conditions pour que des
consommateurs achètent des biens et des
services c'est la fameuse loi de say
dont je vous ai parlé au début on
l'appelle aussi loi des débouchés
c'est la production qui ouvre des
débouchés aux produits écrit c'est pour
comprendre la loi il faut décomposer
l'enchaînement des phénomènes
économiques d'abord les entreprises
produisent des biens et des services
elle verse ensuite des revenus salaires
et profits à la hauteur de leur
production grâce à ses revenus versés
les consommateurs disposent d'un pouvoir
d'achat par conséquent les entreprises
écoulent leurs biens et leurs services
et donc elles peuvent continuer de
produire on revient au point de départ
seconde grande idée jean-baptiste-say
conçoit la monnaie comme un voile
autrement dit et la monnaie n'est qu'une
marchandise intermédiaire entre d'autres
marchandises des produits ou des
services qui s'échange contre d'autres
produits ou services la théorie
économique baptisera cette idée la
neutralité de la monnaie ce qui signifie
que la monnaie n'a aucun impact sur
l'activité économique
elle est neutre
c'est explique que nous conte fondons
ordinairement la monnaie et la richesse
produite lorsque les consommateurs n'ont
pas assez d'argent pour acheter les
biens et services le problème n'est pas
le manque de monnaie mais l'insuffisance
de la richesse produite dont l'argent
n'est qu'une expression une contrepartie
monétaire
quatrième référence des principes de
l'économie politique et de l'impôt david
ricardo ce livre est une référence
capitale peut être encore plus que la
richesse des nations parce qu'il a
alimentés toute la réflexion économique
jusqu'à nos jours après sa publication
en 1817 il est devenu la référence
absolue de la discipline pendant 50 ans
c'est un les livres que marx a lu très
attentivement
lorsqu'il a voulu se mettre à l'économie
après avoir étudié le droit et la
philosophie on considère aujourd'hui
david ricardo comme le premier véritable
économistes adam smith était davantage
un philosophe et les économistes
contemporains se servent encore de ses
analyses le titre du livre aurait pu
être simplement des principes de
l'économie politique puisque c'est un
traité général d'économies mais je pense
que ricardo a ajouté et de l'impôt parce
que 10 chapitres sur 32 c'est à dire un
peu plus de 30% des chapitres sont
consacrés à l'impôt sinon les autres
chapitres parle de la valeur et de la
répartition du produit national du
commerce international de la monnaie de
la banque et de l'enfant la réflexion de
ricardo est forcément orienté par les
problèmes économiques de l'angleterre de
son époque
la question de la stabilité de la
monnaie les corn laws les lois
protectionnistes qui empêché
l'importation de céréales moins cher les
emprunts liés aux guerres napoléoniennes
où les crises sociales engendrées par le
remplacement des ouvriers par des
machines ricardo y consacrent l'avant
dernier chapitre du livre sa réflexion
est aussi un débat avec d'autres auteurs
de l'époque par exemple ils discutent
les idées des dames smith grâce auquel
il avait découvert en lisant la richesse
des nations sa vocation d'économistes
encore il donne son avis sur certaines
théories de malthus sur la forme des
principes de l'économie politique et de
l'impôt n'est pas super facile à lire
mais ça reste accessible pour l'honnête
homme qui veut découvrir à la base de la
théorie classique le propos est
globalement clair il n'y a pas de jargon
et ricardo donne des exemples comme jean
baptiste c'est ce dont je viens de vous
parler ricardo n'était pas un pur
intellectuelle il avait d'abord fait
fortune dans la finance en fondant à 20
ans sa propre maison de courtage après
il faut quand même s'accrocher pour
aller au bout des six cents pages c'est
le genre de livre dans lequel il faut
avancer progressivement un petit peu
chaque jour et bien sûr en prenant des
notes pour être certain de bien
comprendre
maintenant quelles sont les idées
essentielles du livre je pense que cinq
grandes idées économiques sont
importantes pour votre culture générale
première grande idée ricardo affirme que
le prix et la valeur du travail le
travail est la source de toute valeur
écrit-il à ses yeux lorsqu'on achète un
bien on paye fondamentalement la
quantité de travail nécessaire à sa
fabrication il y a une conséquence
importante de cette idée puisque le prix
dépend de la quantité de travail
nécessaire à la production alors il ne
dépend pas de la quantité de monnaie en
circulation
plus précisément la quantité de travail
déterminer les valeur relative des biens
et des services par exemple s'il faut
dix fois plus de travail pour produire
un livre qu'il n'en faut pour produire
une baguette de pain
le livre coûtera 10 fois plus cher que
la baguette de pain si la quantité de
monnaie en circulation change les prix
affichés du livre et de la baguette de
pain changeront mais pas le fait que le
livre coûte dix fois plus
deuxième grande idée
ricardo dénonce l'effet nocif de la
rente le type de revenus qui n'est tiré
ni du travail ni de la prise de risque
par exemple le propriétaire de
l'appartement que j'habitais est un
rentier car il ne travaille pas pour
recevoir mon loyer et il ne prend
quasiment aucun risque pour générer ce
revenu à part peut-être le risque que
mon chien à les stocks ne dégradent
l'appartement je reviens à ricardo
à ses yeux la rente condamne le pays au
conservatisme tandis que le progrès
économique repose sur la concurrence et
l'investissement il ajoute que la rente
pose aussi un problème politique les
rentiers ont tendance à instrumentaliser
l'état c'était le cas dans l'angleterre
de l'époque afin de continuer à
s'enrichir passivement
troisième grande idée ricardo met en
évidence même s'il n'est pas le premier
à le faire
le phénomène qu'on nomme les rendements
décroissants dans l'économie agricole de
son époque l'accroissement de la
population impose de cultiver de
nouvelles terres or ces nouvelles terres
seront probablement moins fertiles car
la production se concentre au départ sur
les terres les plus fertiles et cette
logique se transpose à d'autres
problématiques économiques je me
souviens par exemple que le drh des
entreprises du cac40 m'avait raconté que
les nouveaux ingénieurs qu'ils
embauchaient était moins compétents que
ceux qui travaillaient déjà chez eux
parce que le nombre d'ingénieurs très
compétent et limité à l'échelle mondiale
et par conséquent le rendement des
ingénieurs décroissait au fur et à
mesure qu'ils en embauchant la loi des
rendements décroissants signifie de
manière plus générale que l'efficience
de la production baisse lorsque le
volume augmente et elle vaut à l'échelle
collective comme individuel il est
difficile d'écrire plus de quelques
heures par jour par exemple
les économistes ultérieure montreront
que cette loi n'est pas absolu et qu'il
existe même une loi inverse dans
l'économie de l'information tout
particulièrement les rendements sont
croissants par exemple les coûts de
production d'une vidéo youtube sont les
mêmes que la vidéo fasse sens sans milou
10 millions de vues 12 soit dit en
passant la supériorité de la stratégie
consistant à produire peu de vidéos de
bonne qualité plutôt qu'une grande
quantité de vidéos passable pour
l'expliquer plus concrètement cela coûte
forcément moins cher de produire une
seule vidéo qu'ils fassent 100000 vu ce
qui n'est pas exceptionnel plutôt que
100 vidéos qu'ils fassent mille vu
chacune
quatrième grande idée
ricardo est d'abord la théorie dite des
avantages comparatifs qui corrige la
théorie de l'avantagent absolu d adam
smith dont je vous ai parlé à propos de
la division du travail d'après ricardo
pour se spécialiser dans la production
d'un bien un pays n'a pas besoin d'être
le moins cher dans l'absolu il suffit
qu'il soit moins cher comparativement
aux pays avec lequel il va commercer ça
se démontre avec des calculs simples
mais ces calculs ne sont pas importants
pour votre culture générale ce qui est
important c'est que la conclusion
logique de la théorie des avantages
comparatifs et que n'importe quel pays
et gagnent à s'ouvrir au commerce
international vous allez voir que le
prochain économistes dont je vais vous
parler conteste cette conclusion la
théorie des avantages comparatifs est
aussi à l'origine du pessimisme de
ricardo dans sa perspective la dynamique
du libre échange ne permettra plus
d'augmenter la production une fois que
toutes les terres du monde entier seront
cultivés de manière optimale l'économie
mondiale atteindra alors ce que ricardo
appelle l' état stationnaire la terre ne
rapportera plus suffisamment pour faire
face au développement démographique
cinquième et dernière grande idée ricard
2 donne son nom à ce qu'on appelle
l'équivalence ricardienne cette idée dit
qu'à long terme la dette publique
équivaut à l'impôt c'est-à-dire que la
dette publique contractée aujourd'hui
sera remboursée avec les impôts de
demain dans les deux cas la population
finances l'état la dette publique c'est
de l'argent qui va des particuliers vers
l'état l'impôt c'est aussi de l'argent
qui va des particuliers vers l'état même
si ce ne sont pas les mêmes particulier
ricardo précise d'ailleurs que la dette
publique n'est pas un transfert de
ressources entre les générations mais un
transfert de tous les contribuables vers
les riches qui ont prêté leur argent
5e référence système national d'économie
politique friedrich list cette référence
est importante en économie parce que
c'est la meilleure défense théorique du
protectionnisme c'est à dire de la
stratégie économique consistant à
protéger et à favoriser la production
nationale en limitant les importations
ou en les soumettant à des droits de
douane élevés plus précisément le
système national d'économie politique de
friedrich list est la source de la
théorie qu'on appelle le protectionnisme
éducateurs et cette théorie exposé en
1840 n'est pas obsolète loin de là car
les opposants au libre-échange s'en
servent encore dans le débat public
contemporain
la plupart des manuels d'économie ne
donne pas une grande place à ce livre
mais les doutes grandissants sur les
bienfaits de la mondialisation depuis
les années 2000 ont remis la réflexion
de liste au premier plan notamment aux
états unis l'édition française
l'ouvragé avait été conçu et écrit pour
l'essentiel à paris l'édition française
est préfacé par le démographe médiatique
emmanuel todd qui est lui partisan d'un
protectionnisme à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
sur la forme le système national
d'économie politique est très lisible
d'ailleurs liste lui-même évoque la
question du style dans la préface il dit
qu'il a fait un effort pour écrire
uniquement avec l'arte mais qu'un ami
l'a effrayée en lui disant qu'il avait
trouvé de beaux passages il ne veut pas
être éloquent il ne veut pas à susciter
une émotion esthétique chez les lecteurs
parce que cela les empêchera de juger de
la solidité de son argumentation à ses
yeux donc un style recherché ne convient
pas de l'économie je le cite la clarté
et la simplicité
tels sont dans cette science les
qualités essentielles
c'est quoi l'essentiel sur le fond
maintenant l'idée fondamentale de liste
c'est que le libre échange n'est pas la
panacée mais la stratégie commerciale
qui profite aux libre échangiste
d'ailleurs dans les faits le libre
échange n'a jamais existé ce sont les
anglais qui l'ont inventée pour asseoir
leur domination
l'angleterre demande aux autres pays
d'ouvrir leur économie après c'est bien
commode après avoir développé sa propre
industrie celle de la laine par exemple
à l'abri de la concurrence et tous les
pays font pareil ils assurent leur
prospérité grâce aux barrières
douanières qui leur ont permis de
protéger la croissance de leur industrie
listes expliquent cette stratégie avec
la métaphore de l'échelle je le cite
c'est une règle de prudence vulgaire
lorsqu'on est parvenu au faîte de la
grandeur de rejeter l'échelle avec
laquelle on l'a atteint à fin dans le
verrou autres le moyen d'y monter après
soir du coup quelle est la bonne
stratégie commerciale une stratégie
commerciale n'est pas bonne ou mauvaise
dans l'absolu le libre échange et le
protectionnisme sont la bonne solution
lorsqu'ils sont adaptés à la phase de
développement économique du pays liste a
été un des premiers auteurs à diviser
l'histoire économique en étape dans le
détail la croissance d'une économie
nationale passe par cinq phases première
phase l'état sauvage deuxième phase
l'état pastorale troisième phase l'état
agricole quatrième phase l'état agricole
manufacturier et enfin cinquième phase
l'état complexe à chaque phase
correspond une organisation des rapports
économiques avec les voisins ainsi le
libre échange a du sens entre des
nations économiquement comparable mais
celles qui sont en retard ont elles
intérêt à se protéger de celles qui sont
plus avancées afin de pouvoir éduquer
leur industrie c'est ça le
protectionnisme éducateurs il est donc
important de noter que c'est une
certaine forme de protectionnisme que
défend liste il est favorable au
protectionnisme éducateur mais il est un
adversaire de ce qu'on peut appeler le
protectionnisme de régression utilisé
par une grande puissance pour empêcher
la concurrence des puissances montantes
d'autres économistes défendront une
version comparable du protectionnisme
par exemple john stuart mill un
économiste libéral britannique du 19e
siècle john stuart mill formalisera la
thèse de liste en élaborant ce qu'on
appelle la doctrine des industries
naissantes qui sera accepté jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle comme une exception
au libre échange on retrouve dans la
doctrine 2000 l'idée de la nécessité
d'éduquer l'industrie nationale autre
version comparable du protectionnisme
l'économiste français et prix nobel en
1988 maurice allais défendra lui à la
fin des années 1990 ce qu'il appellera
un protectionnisme raisonné absolument
nécessaire entre pays de niveau de vie
très différents entre lesquels la
concurrence n'est pas viable on retrouve
l'idée de la nécessité d'une concurrence
équitable entre pays économiquement
comparables
6e référence le capital karl marx cette
référence est très importante pour deux
raisons tout d'abord elle a donné
naissance à la deuxième grande école de
l'histoire de la pensée économique
l'école marxiste cette école se définit
par opposition à la première école
l'école classique qu'elle disqualifie
comme une idéologie bourgeoise servant à
justifier l'exploitation des classes
laborieuses
seconde raison cette référence a eu une
énorme influence
elle a changé concrètement le monde
ainsi que l'ambitionnait marx elle a
inspiré au xxème siècle des expériences
économiques inédites à grande échelle la
russie puis les pays satellites de
l'urss la chine et cuba ont renoncé au
système capitaliste
contrairement aux références précédente
de ma liste le capital ne fait pas
évoluer la discipline économique il l'a
redéfinit complètement comme marx était
un philosophe avant d'être un économiste
il a la profondeur intellectuelle pour
remettre en cause les fondements mêmes
de l'analyse économique traditionnel sa
réflexion accouche de nouveaux concepts
et de nouvelles lois une nouvelle
économie une nouvelle science est né
ainsi le siècle suivant notamment au
cours des trente glorieuses dans les
universités d'europe occidentale c'est à
dire hors urss certains profs
enseigneront l'économie intégralement à
partir du système intellectuel de marx
sans aucune référence aux apports des
économistes classiques si ce n'est pour
les critiques concernant la forme du
capital j'en ai déjà parlé dans la vidéo
où je résume 20 références de sociologie
incontournable le livre comporte plus de
deux mille deux cents pages réparties
sur deux tomes et c'était pas très
facile à lire parce que marque se
développe des analyses profondes dans
lesquelles ils recourent à du
vocabulaire technique issue de plusieurs
disciplines notamment l'économie la
philosophie et le droit maintenant
quelles sont les idées essentielles du
capital
la première chose importante c'est
l'analyse du capitalisme petite
précision marx n'a pas inventé les mots
capitalisme et capitaliste dans le
capital
ces termes existait déjà au xviie siècle
et les écrivains sont servait de plus en
plus depuis le début du 19e siècle après
marx leur a donné une diffusion
exceptionnelle et les a érigé en
concepts majeurs de la pensée je reviens
à son analyse du capitalisme qu'est ce
que le capitalisme le capitalisme repose
sur la propriété privée du capital les
machines à l'époque il oppose donc ceux
qui possèdent les moyens de production
les entrepreneurs capitalistes et ceux
qui ne les possèdent pas les
travailleurs que marx appelle aussi
prolétaires ce qui signifie travailleurs
pauvres contraints de vendre leur force
de travail pour survivre aux
capitalistes reviennent le pouvoir de
décision le profit et le risque aux
prolétaires l'obligation de céder leur
force de travail à un prix fixé par
d'autres ainsi le capitalisme est par
définition inégalitaire
les capitalistes s'enrichissent grâce à
l'exploitation du prolétaire
fondamentalement la clé du profit et le
vol pur et simple de la valeur créée par
l'ouvrier dans la perspective de mars le
capitaliste qui ne travaillent pas la
matière ne travaillent pas du tout son
profit est donc égale à la différence
entre la valeur créée par les
travailleurs et la valeur payer aux
travailleurs le travail impayés de
l'ouvrier voilà ce que j'appelle le
profit écrit marx quel problème le
système capitaliste post il dit deux
problèmes principaux sur le plan social
tout d'abord le capitalisme dégrade les
relations humaines la bourgeoisie
diffuse les moeurs marchande et
substituts ce faisant aux rapports
sociaux traditionnels qui était
essentiellement des rapports entre
personnes des rapports entre chose en
entremêlant indifféremment les peuples
et les hommes l'argent corrompt les
liens sociaux et laissé libre cours aux
tendances basse de l'homme c'est ce
problème que souligner à la fameuse
phrase de marx le capitalisme ne laisse
subsister d'autres liens entre les
hommes que l'effroi d'intérêt et les
dures exigences du paiement
le second problème du système
capitaliste est économique le profit et
limiter la concurrence pousse le
capitaliste à remplacer les hommes en
économie on dit le travail par des
machines ce qu'on appelle le capital
mais cette stratégie tari la véritable
source de son profit l'exploitation des
travailleurs il en découle ce que marx
appelle la baisse tendancielle du taux
de profit le capitaliste compense la
baisse de son profit en réduisant les
salaires des ouvriers ce qui déclenché
la révolution
les théoriciens marxistes 10 plus
techniquement que le capitalisme est
voué à disparaître à cause de ses
contradictions internes voilà pour
l'analyse du capitalisme je passe
maintenant aux trois principaux concepts
économiques du capital qui concerne le
travail la monnaie et le chômage
concernant le travail marx affirme que
c'est la source de valeur il revient
donc à l'idée de ricardo selon laquelle
la valeur des changes d'un bien
correspond à la quantité de travail
nécessaire à sa fabrication en
particulier une machine qui produit des
biens ne crée pas de valeur ce sont
uniquement le travail humain incorporé
en elle et le travail humain nécessaire
pour la faire fonctionner qui engendre
la richesse
concernant la monnaie marx dénonce la
perversion de la logique de l' échange
les économistes classiques pose que
l'argent symbolisée par la lettre k est
un passage obligé pour la circulation
des marchandises symbolisée par la
lettre m ils schématise donc les changes
de la manière suivante m à hem prime
seulement pour marx les économistes
classiques ne prennent pas en compte le
fait que les capitalistes cherche à
accumuler de l'argent voici ce qui se
passe en pratique les capitalistes
concentre la monnaie dans leurs mains et
l'empêchent ainsi de circuler la vraie
séquence de les changes et donc à m à
prime et non pas m am prime cela
signifie que l'argent est un moyen qui
est devenu une fin en soi concernant le
chômage marque se met en évidence
l'existence d'une armée de réserve une
grande quantité de chômeurs est un
avantage pour les capitalistes car cette
masse sociale fait pression à la baisse
sur les salaires des travailleurs si un
ouvrier demandent une augmentation
le patron peut facilement le remplacer
par un chômeur la concurrence implicite
entre les employés et les chômeurs
permet de rémunérer le salarié au niveau
de ce que marx appelle la reproduction
de la force de travail c'est à dire le
niveau de salaire qui assure la survie
immédiate de sa famille
7e référence principe d'économie
politique alfred marshall cette
référence est importante pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est qu'elle
a popularisé la représentation graphique
de l' équilibre du marché vous a
peut-être déjà expliqué l'évolution d'un
prix avec un dessin ou deux courbes se
coupe c'est ce qu'on appelle une croix
de marshall et les économistes ont pris
l'habitude de s'en servir pour analyser
les marchés depuis la publication des
principes d'économie politique d' alfred
marshall
la seconde raison pour laquelle c'est
une référence importante c'est qu'elles
font de la version moderne d'un nouveau
type de raisonnement économique ce qu'on
appelle le marginalisme le principe de
ce raisonnement c'est de s'intéresser à
ce qui se passe lorsque les quantités
varient un petit peu à différents
niveaux plutôt que de considérer
uniquement les quantités totales on
s'intéresse désormais à la différence
que fait une unité supplémentaire du
bien ou du service par exemple on se
rend compte qu'on apprécie moins le
dixième un paquet de chips que le
premier après je ne vais pas vous parler
des raisonnements marginal east de
marshall parce qu'il recourt
systématiquement aux mathématiques dans
ses raisonnements marshall a d'ailleurs
été prof de maths avant de s'intéresser
à l'économie or l'usagé des maths en
école il me laisse sceptique et puis ce
n'est pas très intéressant pour votre
culture générale si vous savez ce qu'est
un raisonnement marchina liste c'est
déjà très bien les principes d'économie
politique d' alfred marshall reprennent
l'essentiel de son cours d'économie à
cambridge la prestigieuse université du
sud est du royaume uni ils rendront
marshall célèbre dans le monde entier et
ils deviendront le manuel d'économie de
référence dans les systèmes académique
anglo saxons à partir du tournant du 20e
siècle au point que lorsque kane ce qui
a été l'élève de marshall
lorsqu'au début des années 1920 kane lui
a fait part de son désir de devenir
économistes marshall a lui a répondu
qu'il avait déjà dit tout ce qu'il y a à
savoir en économie dans ses principes
d'économie politique
je pense que les qualités de forme de ce
manuel explique en partie son succès
marchal n expose que les conclusions de
ces raisonnement mathématique et il
repousse les démonstrations qui
n'intéresse pas le plus grand nombre en
fin de chapitre en outre son style est
simple léger et dépourvu de jargon le
propos est globalement claire et même
vraiment clair pour un livre de théorie
économique le seul défaut à mes yeux
c'est que les phrases et les paragraphes
sont parfois longs qu'est ce qui est
important sur le fond maintenant le
premier élément important c'est que
marshall définit ce qu'est l'économie
dans la préface des principes d'économie
politique
l'économie dit la première phrase est
une étude de l'humanité dans les
affaires ordinaires de la vie
en résumé pour marshall la science
économique étudie la richesse mais elle
étudie surtout l'homme il ajoute qu'elle
a la responsabilité morale d'aider à
réduire la pauvreté et la pénibilité du
travail ouvrier marshall continue à
clarifier ce qu'est l'économie dans les
chapitres suivants dans le premier livre
notamment livre qu'il appelle enquête
préliminaire il parle de la méthode de
la science économique et du type de
savoir quels produits le deuxième
élément important pour votre culture
générale ce sont les fameuses croix de
marshall que j'ai mentionnés dès le
départ les croisements des courbes de
l'offre et de la demande sont devenu une
banalité de l'enseignement de l'est
conomie on les trouve depuis lors dans
tous les manuels sur le plan théorique
la croix de marshall représentait la loi
de l'offre et de la demande la baisse du
prix d'un bien entraîne l'augmentation
de la quantité demandée c'est la loi de
la demande car les consommateurs peuvent
en acheter davantage
l'augmentation du prix d'un bien
entraîne l'augmentation de la quantité
offerte c'est la loi de l'offre car les
perspectives de profits sont meilleures
après marshall précise qu'il n'existe
pas d' équilibre général de l'économie à
ses yeux l'équilibré existe uniquement
sur le marché de chaque bien le marché
des tomates par exemple un équilibre est
donc toujours un équilibre partiel le
troisième élément important pour votre
culture générale c'est le concept des
économies d'échelle l'idée c'est que
plus une entreprise produit plus elle
peut répartir et diluer ses coûts fixes
par exemple si une entreprise qui
produit 1000 tomate a besoin d'un
comptable elle a toujours besoin d'un
seul comptable lorsqu'elle produit dix
mille tomates les frais de comptabilité
nécessaires à la production d'une seule
tomates ont donc baissé marshall en
déduit ce qu'il appelle à la loi des
rendements non proportionnelle deux
forces se pose lorsque le volume de
production augmentent d'un côté
l'entreprise bénéficient d'économies
d'échelle mais de l'autre le phénomène
des rendements décroissants que je vous
ai expliqué lorsque je vous ai parlé de
la 4è référence des principes de
l'économie politique et de l'impôt de
david ricardo les rendements
décroissants rang 2e la production plus
coûteuses je reprends l'exemple de
l'entreprise de tomates en produisant en
plus de tomates d'un côté elle profite
du fait que certains coûts fixes tels
les frais de comptabilité n'augmente pas
mais de l'autre côté par exemple comme
l'avait montré ricardo les nouvelles
terres que l'entreprise doit cultiver
pour produire plus de tomates sont
probablement moins fertiles que les
premières terres qu'elle avait
sélectionné bref lorsqu'on veut produire
plus certaines dynamiques font baisser
le coût de production d'autres le
renchérissent d'où l'intérêt du
raisonnement marginal east il faut
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe lorsque
les quantités varient un petit peu à
différents niveaux
8e référence théorie générale de
l'emploi de l'intérêt et de la monnaie
john maynard keynes comme le capital de
marx la théorie générale de l'emploi de
l'intérêt et de la monnaie de kane ce
qu'on abrège en théorie générale cette
référence est elle aussi très importante
à la fois parce qu'elle a créé une
nouvelle école de pensée économique et
parce qu'elle a eu une influence énorme
même s'il faut le dire inférieure à
l'influencent du capital de marx sur le
plan des idées keynes a donc créé la
troisième grande école économique après
l'école classique et l'école marxiste
comme marx il s'oppose à l'école
classique mais sans remettre en cause le
capitalisme il consacre le premier
paragraphe de la théorie générale a posé
son refus des théories classiques dont
ils dénoncent l' influence dans les
milieux dirigeants et universitaire
l'idée fondamentale qui l'oppose aux
classiques et que l'activité économique
est instable à court terme en vertu de
quoi l'état à la responsabilité
d'intervenir afin de réduire les effets
de court terme d'une crise sur le
bien-être de la population
c'est ce que dit sa célèbre formule à
long terme nous serons tous morts on
comprend mieux l'idée avec la phrase
suivante les économistes se fixe une
tâche peu utiles s'ils peuvent seulement
nous dire que lorsque l'orage sera
passée l'océan se rappela à nouveau
cette nouvelle conception de l'économie
n'est bien sûr dans le contexte des
graves crises économiques de
l'entre-deux-guerres elle s'impose plus
précisément pour deux raisons tout
d'abord l'idée classique que la
prospérité reviendra automatiquement
après un certain temps cette idée ne
répond pas au désespoir des populations
placées dans la misère qui ne veulent
pas se contenter d'attendre et on les
comprend ensuite le keynésianisme a
aussi l'avantagé de détourner ces
populations des projets révolutionnaires
sur le plan de l'influencé les idées de
la théorie générale s impose dès sa
publication en 1936 une fois que les
dirigeants ont échoué à résoudre la
crise avec des solutions libérales
classiques comme la baisse des salaires
le new deal du président américain
roosevelt et la politique qui symbolise
l'application des idées keynésiennes
imaginé par les conseillers keynésien du
président qu'on appelle le brain trust
le new deal est un programme de relance
innovants et ambitieux qui tranche avec
l'attentisme du président précédent air
verte hoover surnommé do nothing le
keynésianisme aura ensuite une influence
considérable pendant les trente
glorieuses la plupart des gouvernements
occidentaux s'en réclameront pour
intervenir dans l'économie jusque dans
les années 1970 voilà pour les deux
raisons qui rendent cette référence
incontournable en économie maintenant la
théorie générale et elle est lisible
assez peu le style de kane ce n'est pas
désagréable mais le propos est trop
abstrait dès les premières pages qu'elle
emploie des concepts avancés par exemple
la d utilité marginale et ils
développent des descriptions théorique
compliqué à suivre du coup c'est presque
impossible à lire pour une personne
cultivée qui n'a pas de notion
d'économie ajoutez à cela le fait que
les phrases sont parfois très longue et
qu'il faut en plus se coltiner les
équations mathématiques et vous
comprenez ma recommandation
économisez votre temps je passe au fond
de la théorie générale quelles sont les
idées essentielles pour votre culture
générale il ya tout d'abord les idées
qui fonde la conception de l'économie de
kembs ils s'opposent aux classiques et
aux néo classique avec trois idées
première idée il existe deux niveaux de
l'analyse économique la microéconomie
d'une part le niveau des acteurs et la
macroéconomie d'autre part le niveau des
phénomènes globaux dans l'économie
néoclassique la réflexion passe du
niveau micro au niveau macro grâce à un
raisonnement par récurrence si une
propriété est vérifiée pour un agent
économique qu'elle est également pour
deux agents économiques alors on peut
généraliser et conclure que la propriété
est vérifiée pour la société toute
entière or keynes conteste cette
généralisation des propriétés économique
au niveau macro cela signifie donc que
le raisonnement économique n'est pas le
même à l'échelle de la société et à
l'échelle des acteurs
deuxième idée je vous en ai déjà parlé
l'économie est fondamentalement instable
pour keynes la prospérité dépend à
l'excès d'un certain climat
sociopolitique or la confiance en
l'avenir est un sentiment éminemment
mimétique comme le révèle le
fonctionnement des marchés boursiers
c'est en métamorphosé en un marché
casino où règnent les spéculateurs
mimétique de très court terme la bourse
est un facteur majeur d'instabilité pour
l'économie pour expliquer cette
dimension mimétique kainz fils une
fameuse métaphore la métaphore du
concours de beauté je le cite la
technique du placement peut être comparé
à ces concours organisé par les journaux
ou les participants ont à choisir aller
ici plus jolis visages parmi une
centaine de photographies le prix étant
attribué à celui dont les préférences
s'approche le plus de la sélection
moyenne opéré par l'ensemble des
concurrents
kane ce qui était lui-même un
spéculateur à succès était très
conscient de la dimension psychologique
de l'investissement investir avec succès
disait-il 7 anticipé les anticipations d
autres troisième idée juste en ai parlé
au début l'économie peut requérir
l'intervention de l'état contrairement à
ce que disent les classiques les crises
ne se résolvent pas d'elle-même kane se
défend plus précisément cette idée avec
un argument moral la puissance publique
a le devoir de contrecarrer les effets
de court terme d'une crise économique
sur le bien-être de la population et
aussi avec un argument économique l'état
a aussi intérêt à éviter que la
dépression ne fasse irrémédiablement
régresser l'économie pour keynes
l'intervention économique de l'état doit
se focaliser sur un objectif la
réduction du chômage pour ce faire
l'état doit investir très largement
jusqu'à assurer le plein emploi la
reprise de la demande qui en résultera
remplira les carnets de commandes des
entreprises et stimulera ainsi la
reprise de la production je passe
maintenant aux idées qui décrivent le
fonctionnement de l'économie il y en a
trois principales qui sont importantes
pour votre culture générale première
idée kainz affirme que la demande créée
le dynamisme économique cette idée
renverse le postulat de l'économie
classique
après la loi de celle dont je vous ai
parlé en effet c'est au contraire
l'offre qui engendre la croissance mais
pour kent tout part de la demande si les
entreprises anticipent qu'elles auront
des débouchés alors allez s'investissent
et l embauche et alors les salaires
augmentent en revanche si les ménages
consomment moins les entreprises
réagissent en réduisant leur niveau
d'investissement est un cercle vicieux
s'enclenche
deuxième idée kainz affirme aussi que
les prix sont rigides dans la théorie
classique au contraire les prix bougent
les classiques affirme que des
changements des conditions de production
se traduisent dans un premier temps par
des changements de prix mais pour keynes
ce sont les quantités qui bouge à ses
yeux la concurrence bloque les prix car
toute modification de prix a un impact
négatif perte de clients dans le cas
d'une hausse de prix perte de profits
dans le cas d'une baisse par conséquent
des changements des conditions de
production se répercute d'abord sur les
quantités produites et enfin troisième
idée kainz affirme que la monnaie n'est
pas neutre dans la théorie classique la
monnaie n'est qu'un voile elle sert
purement et simplement à permettre les
changes elle a donc vocation à circuler
mais pour keynes la circulation de la
monnaie est entravée par le phénomène de
la thésaurisation
thésauriser ça veut dire amasser de
l'argent pour kembs les agents
économiques préfèrent conserver la
monnaie par précaution ou bien dans la
tente d'une meilleure occasion
d'employer leurs fonds
9e référence capitalisme socialisme et
démocratie
joseph schumpeter ce livre est important
en économie parce que c'est l'analyse de
référence de l'entrepreneur et de
l'innovation cette analyse a tant marqué
les esprits qu'on parle aujourd'hui de
l'entrepreneur schumpétérien pour
qualifier l'entrepreneur qui prend le
risque d'innover certains disent que
capitalisme socialisme et démocratie et
le livre d'économie le plus important du
21e siècle
non pas du 20e siècle parce que la
théorie de l'innovation de schumpeter
permet de comprendre les transformations
de l'économie mondiale par la
technologie je vous donner des exemples
concrets dans quelques instants ce livre
est un classique dans les pays anglo
saxons notamment aux états unis car je
me battais était prof à harvard mais il
est beaucoup moins connu en france il
n'y a d'ailleurs ni édition kindle ni
même édition de poche je lis lui il y a
une dizaine d'années sur le conseil de
jean marc daniel qui était alors prof à
le s&p et j'avais bien aimé le titre
capitalisme socialisme et démocratie ne
laisse pas penser qu'il s'agit d'un
livre sur l'innovation parce
qu'effectivement ce n'est qu'une partie
du propos schumpeter réfléchit plus
généralement au fonctionnement du
capitalisme à la tendance à la
socialisation des économies capitalistes
et enfin à la correspondance entre le
régime économique est le régime
politique tout particulièrement la
démocratie ce n'est donc pas uniquement
un livre de théorie économique
schumpeter interroge le fonctionnement
de la société sous divers angles
économique bien sûr mais aussi
politiques philosophiques ou encore
sociologique et il apporte des réponses
originales sur la forme capitalisme
socialisme et démocratie est plutôt
difficile à lire schumpeter adopte
certes le ton de la conversation mais il
emploie des constructions de phrases
compliquées souvent trop longues et ses
paragraphes sont également trop long je
pense que ces choix de vocabulaire et
les références culturelles rebuteront
certainement le lecteur de 2021 enfin
l'édition française comme les éditions
américaines apparemment fait mal aux
yeux tant les caractères son petit ça
coûte moins cher en papier maintenant
quelles sont les idées essentielles du
livre il ya d'abord comme je vous l'aï
dit au début ce que schumpeter écrit sur
l'entrepreneur l'entrepreneur est un
agent économique exceptionnelle son
comportement et sa psychologie ne
correspondent pas à ceux de l'agent
économique ordinaire lequel veut
simplement satisfaire ses besoins et
poursuivre sa routine l'entrepreneur lui
à des motivations et une conduite
différente et il développe des qualités
exceptionnelles pour réaliser ses désirs
schumpeter explique que l'entrepreneur
est à la fois motivé par le désir de
renouveler la réalité économique et par
l'ambition de créer un empire qui soient
le signe de sa puissance dans cette
perspective l'entrepreneur échappe à la
rationalité optimise attriste lui il
n'est que ne mise pas ses efforts et il
ne consent pas d effort pour jouir il
trouve plutôt sa satisfaction dans
l'effort lui-même l'entrepreneur peut
être plus particulièrement
d'exceptionnelles qualités de vision et
de volonté il est capable de voir les
choses sans pouvoir les justifier par
intuition et de se donner à lui même un
horizon inconnu radicalement incertain
qui ne relèvent pas de l'anticipation
rationnelle c'est difficile en lisant ce
profil de ne pas penser à steve jobs
jeff bezos ou elon musk cette théorie de
l'entrepreneur nous amène ensuite à la
théorie du capitalisme en effet pour
schumpeter l'entrepreneur et l'acteur
essentiel de l'évolution économique un
agent radicalement différent du
producteur et du consommateur tel que
conçu par la théorie économique ce qui
fait de lui le héros du capitalisme
c'est qu'il est le fer de lance de
l'innovation il combine en lui l'esprit
de décision et la capacité de découvrir
dans la masse des innovations
scientifiques celles qui permettent
d'une part d'augmenter la productivité
avec des innovations de procédés de mode
de production ou de matières premières
et d'autre part de satisfaire une
demande non encore révélé avec des
innovations de produits ou de débouchés
ainsi sans lui le progrès technique et
resterait lettre morte or l'innovation
est au coeur du processus économique le
processus capitaliste total écrit
schumpeter ne consistant rien d'autre
que dans l'exploitation de tels chance
d'investissement au fur et à mesure
qu'elle et entre dans le champ d'action
de l'entrepreneur on arrive au fameux
concept que connaissent toutes les
personnes qui ont déjà eu un cours sur
la croissance économique pour schumpeter
la croissance économique est
fondamentalement un processus de
destruction créatrice
l'idée est que des entreprises obsolète
font faillite et sont remplacées par de
nouvelles entreprises dont les
fondateurs ont conçu des produits
innovants qui correspondent à une
demande par exemple les entreprises qui
produisait des lecteurs cd ont
progressivement disparu et nous avons
aujourd'hui les entreprises qui
produisent des smartphones autre exemple
intéressant l'entreprise apple c'est
cannibaliser elle même en créant
l'iphone puisque ce produit a remplacé
l'ipod
pour schumpeter le processus de
destruction créatrice déterminent
l'évolution générale de l'économie les
cycles économiques s'explique par le
progrès technique et tout
particulièrement par le développement de
ce qu'il appelle des grappes
d'innovation les entrepreneurs et les
innovations apparaissent groupe et après
et autour d'une innovation radicale par
exemple la création du smartphone a fait
émerger tout un tas d'entreprises et
d'innovateurs autour de ce nouvel
instrument qui a pris une place
prédominante dans nos vies la théorie de
la destruction créatrice nous amène au
dernier élément intéressant dans
capitalisme socialisme et démocratie
écrivant dans la crise des années 1930
et à une époque où la planification de
l'urss passe pour un succès schumpeter
prophétise la fin du capitalisme la
partie 2 du livre s'intitule le
capitalisme peut-il survivre à ses yeux
tant la logique économique que le climat
social font tendre les sociétés
occidentales vers la planification
socialiste d'une part la concurrence
s'autodétruit puisqu'elle écrasé les
profits qui sont le sens des entreprises
d'autre part les populations aspirent au
confort médiocre des économies
planifiées les mentalités finiront donc
par écoeurer les entrepreneurs qui
laisseront la société au moins des
planificateurs
10e référence la route de la servitude
friedrich hayek cette référence est
importante son économie parce que si la
plus fameuse condamnation de
l'intervention de l'état dans l'économie
voici le sens du titre la route de la
servitude c'est la route sur laquelle
avance les sociétés où la puissance
publique se permet d'intervenir dans
l'économie
hayek pense que l'intrusion de l'état
dans des sphères qui ne relèvent pas de
sa responsabilité amène nécessairement
au totalitarisme avec une telle thèse et
puis un titre bien senties il faut le
dire aussi avec une telle thèse la route
de la servitude est devenu un classique
de la pensée libérale on comprend mieux
la virulence du propos de hayek en
prenant en compte le contexte lui même
émigré aux états unis pour fuir le
nazisme il commence à écrire ce livre au
début des années 1940 une époque où
hitler et staline sont au pouvoir ils
jouissent d'une grande influence dans le
monde développé il faut reconnaître que
pour un homme qui aime la liberté et
c'est très préoccupant il veut donc
réveillé les consciences il fustige les
classes politiques converti au dirigisme
économique qui s'imagine en rempart
contre le totalitarisme
alors qu'elle lui ouvre la voie à la
publication de la route de la servitude
en 1944 le succès est immédiat en
angleterre depuis lors plus de 2
millions d'exemplaires en ont été vendus
dans plus de 20 langues
du point de vue de la forme le propos
est globalement accessible hayek
s'exprime plutôt simplement sans jargon
les seules difficultés viennent à mon
sens des références au contexte de
l'époque et de la longueur des
paragraphes mais le propos est
suffisamment intéressant pour que le
lecteur de 2021 fasse l'effort d'aller
au bout des 270 pages qu'en retenir sur
le fond maintenant la thèse fondamentale
et comme je voulais dit que les
politique économique interventionniste
même entreprise avec les meilleures
intentions du monde akkouche toujours de
l'arbitraire du pouvoir et de la
destruction des libertés individuelles
hayek montre tout d'abord que la liberté
reflux au 20e siècle elle avait pourtant
progressé sur le plan théorique au
xviiie siècle puis sur le plan pratique
au 19e siècle cela avait favorisé la
liberté économique le développement des
sciences et l'élévation du niveau de vie
mais malheureusement le progrès de la
liberté a aussi fait naître la volonté
d'éradiquer les derniers maux sociaux
par l'intervention de l'état dans la vie
économique
le socialisme qui était né en réaction
au libéralisme lors de la révolution
française le socialisme a alors imposé
sa conception de la liberté prendre le
pouvoir pour instaurer l'égalité de fait
au détriment de la conception libérale
de l'égalité défendu par hayek qui
consiste à lutter contre l'oppression
quel est le problème avec la conception
socialiste de la liberté c'est qu'en
pratique il est impossible d'identifier
un but social unique qui serait autre
chose que les faits identiques d'un
grand nombre d'individus cela signifie
qu'il faudra forcément oppressé la
minorité des indices du qui ne partagent
pas ce but la liberté individuelle
affirme friedrich hayek est incompatible
avec la suprématie d'un but unique
auquel toute la société est subordonnée
en permanence un autre problème c'est
que si on confie la réalisation du but
social unique à l'état il va
probablement vouloir fixer un but encore
plus ambitieux pour justifier de
repousser un peu plus les limites de son
pouvoir hayek craint que cette logique
aboutissent à ce qu'il appelle la
société militaire dépourvue de risques
car privé de choix à opposer à la
société commerciale où la liberté de
choix implique une part de risque un
autre élément essentiel de la route de
la servitude c'est l'analyse de la
méthode particulière à laquelle recourt
le socialisme pourra atteindre son idéal
de liberté
le planisme c'est-à-dire installé comme
en urss un système central d'économie
planifiée après la suppression de la
propriété privée les socialistes disent
que c'est une méthode rationnelle parce
qu'en abolissant la concurrence elle
abolit l'incertitude cependant cette
méthode pose des problèmes dont
notamment les suivants en se focalisant
sur l'égalité des richesses elles
négligent le niveau absolu des richesses
et elle rend ainsi possible la pénurie
sur le plan politique elle aboutit à
favoriser certaines catégories sociales
aux dépens d'autres et elle donne le
pouvoir aux idéalistes et aux
techniciens en mettant les gens dans
l'insécurité économique elle leur fait
perdre le goût de la liberté économique
que la presse et l'enseignement dénigre
elle va toujours plus loin que son but
affiché de libération des soucis
matériels c'est à dire que des hommes de
pouvoir instrumentalise la méthode
socialiste on arrive à la thèse de la
route de la servitude la méthode
socialiste a abouti au totalitarisme
c'est à dire à un système politique qui
impose à la société dans son ensemble
ainsi qu aux individus qui la composent
la toute puissance d'un état et d'une
idéologie derrière la recherche utopique
de l'égalité parfaite selon des mérites
prétendument objectif il y a dans les
faits un groupe qui impose son idéal
grâce à la propagande dans une société
libre de multiples propagande s'opposent
qui poursuivent de multiples objectifs
indépendant dans la société planifier la
propagande unique est étendue à tous les
domaines arts sports loisirs afin
d'inscrire toute activité dans les fin
de l'idéologie au pouvoir la méthode
socialiste rend donc nécessaire de fixer
définitivement une vérité totalitaire ce
qui est contraire à l'esprit et à la
méthode de la science
pour hayek cette destruction totale de
la liberté et communaux socialisme et au
nazisme le second se situant en réalité
dans la continuité du premier
on dit en référence la grande
transformation karl polanyi je viens de
vous parler du livre de chevet des
libéraux la route de la servitude je
vais maintenant vous parler du livre et
qui passe pour la meilleure réputation
de l'idéologie libérale en économie
c'est la critique non marxiste de
référence des sociétés de marché pour
karl polanyi en particulier l'idée du
marché autorégulateur illustré par
l'image de la main invisible cette idée
n'est qu'un mythe
pourquoi le livre s'intitule t-il la
grande transformation parce que paula
n'y parle des mutations économiques et
sociales entraînées par la révolution
industrielle
mais ce n'est pas exactement cela qui
fait du livre une référence
incontournable en économie l'intérêt de
l'ouvragé réside dans l'analyse à la
fois économiques anthropologique et
sociologique de l'instauration de
l'économie de marché tout d'abord en
angleterre dès le xviiie siècle puis
dans l'ensemble des états européens
c'est cette analyse qui permet à paul
annie de montrer que l'économie de
marché n'est ni naturelle ni efficace
sur la forme la grande transformation
n'est pas facile à lire déjà il y en a
pour plus de 400 pages avec une police
relativement petites dans l'édition
française ce qui n'est pas de nature à
encourager le lecteur hésitant ensuite
il faut se taper de longs développements
historiques parfois assez technique par
exemple sur les lois sur les pauvres en
vigueur en angleterre au début du 19e
siècle non seulement c'est long pour
quelqu'un qui comme moi préfèrent aller
à l'essentiel mais l'organisation du
propos et le style son psy alambiquée
que ça en devient chiant
maintenant quelles sont les idées
essentielles du livre la première idée
essentielle c'est que le marché n'est
pas naturel karl polanyi affirme que
l'économie de marché n'est pas inscrite
dans la nature humaine en effet elle a
été construite au cours de l'histoire
des sociétés et elle n'a été identifié
comme un phénomène que depuis le début
du 19e siècle il y à une confusion dans
l'interprétation de la réalité on a
confondu le marché avec le commerce
alors que le marché ne constitue qu'une
forme de commerce parmi d'autres tels la
réciprocité dans le don la
redistribution par un centre de
production ou encore l'administration
domestique comme dans les économies
autarcique autant de formes qui ont
prévalu en europe jusqu'à la fin du
moyen âge le marché généralisée n'a pas
existé en tout lieu et à toute époque
écrit polani d'un point de vue
historique le marché n'apparaît pas du
tout comme l'aboutissement naturel des
commerces locaux intérieurs ou
extérieurs
d'un point de vue anthropologique
l'homme n'a pas été de tout temps
caractérisé par un penchant l échange
pour polani l'image de l'homo economicus
aînés du travail idéologique d'une
classe de commerçants soutenu par l'êta
dans les faits l'économie a toujours été
encastré dans la société c'est à dire
que les relations matériel entre les
gens étaient subordonnés aux relations
humaines le désencombrement c'est à dire
la déconnexion de l'économie des autres
dimensions de la société cela s'est
produit lorsque tous les objets des
changes notamment le travail la terre et
la monnaie ont été soumis à la logique
marchande la deuxième idée essentielle
du livre c'est que la société a réagi à
l'extension du marché si cette réaction
était plutôt le fait de certaines
classes sociales notamment les
propriétaires terriens et le travailleur
les libéraux ils ont paradoxalement eux
mêmes contribué dans une certaine mesure
à la fois pour assurer le libre
fonctionnement du marché et pour le
sauver de ses propres excès les
principaux risques étaient la baisse des
prix agricoles par le libre échange et
plus généralement la concurrence
étrangère la volatilité des prix et de
la monnaie
mais le plus gros problème selon paul
and i c'est le choc culturel que
représente l'organisation de la société
sur le mode du marché en laissant les
travailleurs dans la précarité le marché
autorégulateur a compromis la dimension
humaine de la société c'est pourquoi ce
sont les classes moyennes et les
aristocrates paternaliste et non pas la
classe ouvrière qui ont agi en faveur de
la réglementation polani aimé donc
l'hypothèse que ce sont les mouvements
de protection sociale et territoriale
plutôt que le marché qui sont les
émanations spontanée de la population
la troisième idée essentielle du livre
c'est que polani prédit la fin de
l'économie libérale il décrit comment
les excès du libéralisme ont donné
suffisamment d'ampleur à c contre
mouvement pour causer l'effondrement du
modèle qui s'était imposé au 19e siècle
cette évolution a détruit l'équilibré
international en renversant de nombreux
régimes démocratiques nationaux et en
engendrant les deux guerres mondiales
pour polani la crise de 1929 et le point
de basculement vers la mort du
libéralisme sur le plan économique
l'intervention de l'état et est
désormais indispensable pour remédier au
dérèglement du marché et le rétablir
dans son équilibre initial il est
possible de construire une société
industrielle en dehors de l'institution
du marché à la condition de mettre le
travail la terre et la monnaie hors
marché c'est à dire en pratique en
fixant leur valeur par des mécanismes de
négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux et l'état c'est dans cette
perspective que paula n'y voit les
totalitarismes fascistes et communistes
comme des projets volontariste pour ré
encastré l'économie dans la société
12e référence la crise économique de
john kenneth galbraith
celui devrait être important parce que
c'est l'analyse de référence de la crise
économique la plus célèbre celle de 1929
john kenneth galbraith espérait que son
travail permettrait de tirer les leçons
de cette grande crise et effectivement
la crise de 1929 est devenu un modèle
pour comprendre pourquoi et comment les
crises surviennent ainsi que ce que les
gouvernements peuvent faire pour en
sortir les économistes compare chaque
bulle financière
à la crise de 1929 c'est pourquoi le
livre de galles bresse est toujours en
réimpression depuis qu'il est devenu un
best seller en 1955 pour ma part je l'
ai découvert lors de la crise de 2008
dont l'impact était particulièrement
violent à londres où je vivais alors
j'ai bien aimé ce livre pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord ce n'est pas de la
théorie économique mais plutôt de
l'histoire économique galbraith ne
recourra aucun modèle financier il
raconte concrètement ce que les hommes
auront fait pour précipiter l'économie
mondiale dans un marasme inédit et son
récit est plaisant à lire galles grèce
avoue d'ailleurs dans la préface qu'il a
lui-même pris du plaisir à l'écrire il
dépeint avec humour tout la comédie
humaine et qui entoure l'événement par
exemple les professeurs d'économie qui
clame avant la crise tel nos influences
heures avec le bitcoin que les cours ne
peuvent que continuer à monter puis qui
jure une fois la crise enclenchée que
tout est sous contrôle
sur la forme le texte de galles bresse
et très accessible il n'y a pas de
jargon les phrases ne sont pas trop
longue le style est presque
journalistique et comme je les dis le
propos est concret et parfois drôle
après le récit des événements jour après
jour même si les simples m'a paru à
certains moments trop détaillé donc trop
long il reste fait de longs
développements historiques centrées sur
le rôle de la bourse et il repousse au
dernier chapitre l'analyse des causes de
la crise mais bon il y en a pour moins
de 300 pages et on peut les lire sans
connaissances préalables en économie
qu'est ce qui est essentiel sur le fond
maintenant je commence par vous résumer
très rapidement le récit de galeries
galbe res estime que l'optimisme du 30e
président des états unis calvin coolidge
qui a été président jusqu'en 1929
son optimisme est en partie responsable
de l'aveuglément général du pays certes
il était possible de s'enrichir
rapidement dans les années 1920 mais la
pauvreté était encore très répandue à
partir de 1927 les conditions
économiques notamment la baisse du taux
d'intérêt aux états unis les conditions
économiques rendait plus facile
d'acheter des actions d'où une ruée vers
le marché boursier la logique
spéculative s'enclenche à partir de 1928
les américains veulent gagner de
l'argent très rapidement ils sont ivres
de cette perspective si bien que les
cours on ne cesse de croître ni le
gouvernement ni la banque centrale à
n'intervienne comme il faut la bulle
explose à partir de l'automne 1929 où
les états unis entrent en récession
c'est la panique le 24 octobre 1929
surnommé le jeudi noir les plus
puissants financier décide alors de
soutenir le marché mais la perte de
confiance des américains amènent à
lachute crucial du 29 octobre dans la
panique les acteurs financiers
multiplient les décisions dictées par
l'émotion donc souvent mauvaises et il
accélère ainsi la spirale de la crise
l'effondrement du marché touche
l'ensemble du pays réduisant le commerce
et diminuant la production dans toute
l'économie voilà pour le récit des
événements je passe maintenant au plan
des idées
l'intérêt principal du livre réside dans
l'analyse du mécanisme de la spéculation
le propre de la spéculation c'est qu'on
n'achète pas les actifs pour leur valeur
intrinsèque mais dans l'espoir de les
revendre rapidement et de réaliser ainsi
un profit par exemple vous achetez des
actions de tesla l'entreprise d'elon
musk qui produit des voitures
électriques vous achetez des actions de
cette entreprise non pas parce que vous
pensez qu'elle a un grand avenir qu'elle
va vendre beaucoup de voitures mais
parce que vous pensez que beaucoup de
gens vont continuer d'acheter des
actions de cette entreprise en vertu de
quoi son cours de bourse va monter et
lorsque le cours de l'action aura
atteint un certain niveau vous pourrez
revendre vos actions et réaliser ainsi
un juteux profits j'ai développé cet
exemple pour vous montrer la dimension
éminemment psychologique de la
spéculation galeries explique bien que
ce sont en réalité des croyances et non
pas des mécanismes purement économiques
qui sont à l'origine des crises
financière ces crises sont causées par
une confiance irrationnelle pourtant
présenté comme rationnel voire même
scientifiquement fondées les crises
financières sont causées par une
confiance irrationnelle exacerbée qui
contamine tous les agents sans
discernement de leur statut social ou
culturel bogal bresse la spéculation à
grande échelle repose plus précisément
sur la conviction que les gens du commun
peuvent s'enrichir car ces gens doivent
avoir foi dans la bonté de leur sang la
bhl pour s'enrichir par leur
intermédiaire est encore plus
précisément le dénominateur commun de
tous les épisodes spéculatifs et la
conviction des acteurs qu'ils peuvent
devenir riche sans travailler galbraith
estime que cette mentalité était répandu
dans l'amérique du début du 20e siècle
la dimension psychologique est crucial à
meygal bresse restitue bien la situation
qui a rendu possible la crise de 1929
dans toute sa complexité
l'excès d'optimisme et le mythe de
l'enrichissement rapide ne suffisent pas
à expliquer le gonflement d'une bulle
financière des conditions économiques et
politiques dont notamment l'inaction des
décideurs rendent possible l'emballement
de la logique spéculative dans le détail
à galbraith identifie quatre facteurs
d'une crise financière de grande ampleur
premier facteur un climat d'euphorie
boursière ce qui est un facteur
psychologique
deuxième facteur le développement des
opérations de pure spéculation
troisième facteur une politique fiscale
très favorables à l'accumulation du
capital par les classes privilégiées et
enfin quatrième et dernier facteur d
innovation entre guillemets financière
qui facilite la spéculation et décuple
les profits des intermédiaires
financiers
et effectivement on retrouve souvent ces
quatre facteurs dans les crises
financières ultérieures notamment dans
la crise des subprimes de 2008
13e référence l'air de l'opulence john
kenneth galbraith vous dit peut-être que
deux livres de john kenneth galbraith
dans ma liste ça fait beaucoup
d'ailleurs l'ami prof d'économie auquel
j'ai demandé son avis m'a conseillé de
supprimer cette référence en arguant que
galbraith ne méritent pas de figurer
deux fois dans la liste
c'est vrai que les économistes ne sont
pas fans de galles brice comme il
mesurait plus de 2 m ses adversaires
disait qu'il était un grand économiste
par la taille il avait beau être prof à
harvard et avoir conseillé tous les
présidents américains démocrates dont
notamment roosevelt et kennedy ses idées
des plaisait aux tenants de l'orthodoxie
de la science entre guillemets
économique elles n'apparaissent même pas
dans certaines histoires des idées
économiques c'est pour ça qu'on classe
grèce comme un hétérodoxe c'est à dire
un penseur qui s'écartent d opinion
couramment admise dans sa discipline
alors pourquoi ai-je conserver cette
référence dans ma liste parce que si
l'auteur n'est pas devenue une autorité
en économie ces idées ont été très
influente pour simplifier on peut dire
que l'ère de l'opulence des affluents de
société en anglais on peut dire que ce
livre et l'analyse économique de
référence de la société de consommation
c'est un peu en économie ce qu'est la
société de consommation de baudrillard
en sociologie et l'air de l'opulence est
une référence d'autant plus importante
que ces idées ont dépassé le cadre du
débat strictement économique aux états
unis ce livre est classé comme un des
tous meilleurs ouvrages de non fiction
du 20e siècle et le new york times dit
carrément en exagérant je trouve que ce
livre a forcé l'amérique à réexaminer
ses valeurs c'est vrai qu'il est peu
connu en france il n'en existe aucune
édition récente à ma connaissance mais
il ya quand même de sérieux arguments
pour le considérer comme une référence
importante son succès commercial et
intellectuels s'explique en partie par
le pouvoir de séduction de sa forme
contrairement à la plupart des
économistes john kenneth galbraith
permettent aux profanes de découvrir ses
idées son style est à la fois clair et
éloquent et comme je vous l'aï dit à
propos de son histoire de la crise de
1929 drôle et là encore il y en a pour
moins de 300 pages donc c'est un livre
accessible
maintenant qu'est ce qui est essentiel
sur le fond pour faire simple je vais me
concentrer sur les deux concepts qui
sont restés la filière inversée et le
savoir conventionnels et les replacer
dans l'argumentation de galles bresse
tout d'abord qu'est-ce que la filière
inversé c'est l'idée que le rapport de
force entre le producteur et le
consommateur s'est inversée dans nair le
consommateur à un besoin et il choisit
les produits qui lui permettent de
satisfaire son besoin mais dans les
états unis d'après la deuxième guerre
mondiale les entreprises ne sont plus
soumises aux exigences du consommateur
il n'y a en réalité plus de clients au
roi ce sont les entreprises qui impose
les produits aux consommateurs écrit
galles bresse et non l inverse comment
font-elles pour imposer leurs produits
aux consommateurs elle manipule les gens
par le marketing et la publicité les
grandes firmes en particulier ont un tel
poids économique politique et médiatique
qu'elles ont le pouvoir de créer de
nouveaux besoins on dirait plutôt des
désirs en philosophie de toutes pièces
elles ont développé cette capacité pour
que les ventes puissent suivre
l'explosion de la production après 1945
le concept de la filière inversée révèle
une chose la théorie économique
classique ne décrit plus efficacement la
société américaine des trente glorieuses
la société d'abondance comme l'appelle
galbraith et cela se comprend aisément
l'hyper fondateur de l'économie lee
smith ricardo ou malthus ont fondé leur
théorie dans un monde caractérisé par la
rareté et par la pauvreté mais leurs
idées ne sont plus adaptées à la
situation économique des états unis au
20e siècle par exemple ce n'est plus la
rencontre de l'offre et de la demande
qui fixe les prix puisque les
producteurs ont désormais les moyens de
manipuler les consommateurs
cette inadéquation entre la théorie
économique et le contexte historique me
permet d'introduire le second concept
capitale du livre ce que galbraith
appelle à la sagesse conventionnelle
conventional wisdom en anglais
la sagesse conventionnelle ce sont les
idées accepté par convention dans une
société et qui ont surtout eu le défaut
de ne pas s'adapter aux changements qui
s'opèrent dans cette société
la loi de l'offre et de la demande
relève comme je viens de vous le dire de
la sagesse conventionnelle l'idée que
les crises sont une phase normale des
cycles économiques et qu'elles se
résorbe d'elle-même cette idée relève et
également de la sagesse conventionnelle
mais en particulier elles n'étaient plus
adaptés pour comprendre la crise de 1929
c'est la sagesse conventionnelle affirme
galbraith qui empêche les américains de
poser le bon diagnostic sur leur société
ils ne réalisent pas que le consumérisme
et une impasse car ils confondent
l'essentiel et l'accessoire
ils dépensent toujours plus pour
satisfaire des désirs artificielle qui
ne les rendent pas plus heureux alors
que l'air est pollué que les routes sont
abîmés que les transports publics sont
surchargées que les hôpitaux manquent de
moyens et qu'une grande partie de la
population demeure bloquée dans la
pauvreté pour galles bresse il y avait à
l'époque dans les années 1950 un
déséquilibre entre le secteur privé où
aller tout l'argent et le secteur public
et par conséquent l'état américain avait
le devoir d'investir dans les services
essentiels à la collectivité
14e référence capitalisme et liberté
milton friedman cette référence est
importante en économie parce que c'est
la plus célèbre défense de la liberté
économique elle est moins connue en
france parce que le libéralisme est un
courant de pensée minoritaire dans ce
pays mais les américains considèrent
capitalisme et liberté comme un des
ouvrages clés de la pensée économique
plusieurs magazines influents dont par
exemple time magazine classe même cet
ouvrage parmi les meilleurs livres de
non fiction de tous les temps il s'en
est vendu près d'un million
d'exemplaires en anglais il a été
traduit en 18 langues et ils cumulent
plus de 1500 note sur amazon us où il
est encore numéro un en théorie
économique à l'heure où j'écris le
script de cette vidéo enfin certains
commentaires dithyrambiques présente
carrément capitalisme et liberté comme
je cite le meilleur livre de tous les
temps bon c'est bien sûr exagéré mais ça
révèle bien à l'engouement qu'a suscité
et que continue de susciter le premier
best seller mondial de milton friedman
qui était le chef de file du courant
qu'on appelle le monétarisme parce que
son idée fondamentale et qu'il faut
limiter la quantité de monnaie en
circulation afin d'éviter les problèmes
liés à l'inflation comme souvent même
s'il ya des exceptions si capitalisme et
liberté connaît un tel succès c'est
parce que les lecteurs peuvent
effectivement le lire je ne suis pas un
fan de hedman mais il faut reconnaître
qu'il était un génie pour expliquer de
façon simple les notions les plus
compliqués les gens qui le connaissaient
personnellement disent qu'il était un
grand pédagogue en plus ouverts d'esprit
cela se retrouve dans la prose du livre
friedman écrite dans un style simple et
clair sans jargon il sait raccourcir les
phrases il utilise pas mal de liens
logiques et ils varient la taille des
paragraphes bref l'expression écrite
rend le propos très accessible
certes il faut parfois faire un effort
lorsque cela devient plus conceptuel
mais ce serait injuste de le reprocher à
l'auteur il écrit un livre de théorie
économique il ne parle pas de la pluie
et du beau temps maintenant quelles sont
les idées essentielles du livre la thèse
fondamentale et comme l'indiquent le
titre que capitalisme et liberté vont de
pair pour friedman le système économique
capitaliste est le plus apte à préserver
la liberté individuelle et à favoriser
son épanouissement
la première idée importante et que la
liberté doit être à la fois économiques
et politiques friedman commence le 1er
chapitre part expliqué que la politique
c'est à dire l'organisation de la vie
collective il l'économie c'est-à-dire la
création et la répartition des richesses
la politique et l'économie sont
intimement liés et ce lien se retrouve
au niveau de la liberté individuelle la
liberté économique est essentielle comme
composante primordiale de toute liberté
mais elle est surtout la condition de
possibilité de la liberté politique
cette relation a été démontrée
historiquement par contre à poser dans
les systèmes socialiste ou la
suppression de la liberté économique a
immanquablement entraîner la disparition
de toute liberté inversement d'autres
exemples maintenant lumière d'après
milton friedman la vertu politique de la
liberté économique comme au chili où les
réformes libérales des années 1970-1980
amorcerait une transition vers la
démocratie
cependant la liberté économique ne fait
pas tout d'autres conditions sont donc
nécessaires à l'épanouissement de la
liberté pour friedman le facteur crucial
et de limiter et de décentraliser le
pouvoir politique car sa concentration
dans une instance planificatrice ne peut
qu uniformiser la diversité naturelle du
marché dont bénéficie la société
la deuxième idée importante et que les
interventions de l'état font reculer la
liberté friedman considèrent qu'elles
font plus de mal que de bien quand elles
débordent du cadre légitime de l'action
étatique les grandes avancées de la
civilisation pose-t-il que ce soit dans
l' architecture ou dans la peinture la
science ou la littérature l'industrie ou
l'agriculture ne sont jamais né de
l'intervention d'un gouvernement
centralisé sur le plan monétaire par
exemple friedman dénonce la
responsabilité du contrôle de l'abonné
par l'état dans les désordres
économiques du 20e siècle il accuse
ainsi la banque centrale américaine
d'avoir décupler les effets des
récessions économiques notamment en 1929
où son choix de raréfier la monnaie
aurait précipité le krach boursier ils
dénoncent également la nocivité de la
théorie keynésienne cette théorie
légitime les déficits publics par l'idée
selon laquelle la dépense publique
générerait un cercle vertueux mais dans
les faits les déficits publics rendent
l'économie instable friedman dénonce
encore la nocivité des changes fixes et
du protectionnisme autre entorse à la
liberté économique enfin ils s'opposent
à des interventions étatiques plus
anecdotiques comme les politiques de
lutte contre les discriminations qui
l'accusent de renforcer les préjugés à
ses yeux la liberté économique est le
meilleur remède qui soit puisqu'elle
valorise objectivement la compétence la
troisième idée importante et qu'il faut
limiter le rôle de l'état pour autant si
friedman préfère par principe la liberté
à la contrainte il reconnaît que l'état
n'est pas inutile certaines fonctions
certes réduite mais nécessaires doivent
en effet échoir à l'état l'existence
d'un marché libre et n'élimine
évidemment pas écrit friedman le besoin
de gouvernement au contraire le
gouvernement est essentiel à la fois
comme forum pour déterminer les règles
du jeu et comme arbitre pour interpréter
et faire respecter les règles qui ont
été adoptées fin de la citation l'état
doit plus précisément garantir le
respect de la loi du droit de la
propriété privée et lutter contre la
domination liberticide de certains
monopoles
friedman évoque par exemple le rôle de
l'état sur le plan de l'éducation
si le financement de ce service rentre
dans le champ d'action de l'état celui
ci ne doit toutefois pas en prendre en
charge la prestation l'étape financer le
service mais il ne doit pas le fournir
acquis à l'idée que chaque citoyen
puisse recevoir une éducation de base
friedman considère néanmoins que la
liberté des parents et des
établissements combiné au financement
public par un système de chèque
éducation il considère que c'est la
manière la plus efficace d'assurer
l'égalité autre exemple concernant la
pauvreté friedman avance que
l'implication de l'état devrait se
limiter à la mise en place d'un impôt
négatif ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un
revenu universel ce qui optimiserait
considérablement l'aide sociale tout en
réduisant le poids de la fiscalité et en
protégeant la liberté individuelle
15e référence histoire mondiale de la
spéculation financière charles
kindleberger ce livre est comme son nom
l'indiqué la référence sur les crises
financières l'historien de la finance au
prestigieux et mighty à l'extrême
nord-est des etats-unis charlie kindel
berger fait un compte rendu de la
manière dont la mauvaise gestion de la
monnaie et du crédit a conduit à des
explosions financière au fil des siècles
le titre anglais est plus sexy mes
nièces panique ce crash ce qui signifie
manille paniquée crash publié en 1978 ce
livre a déjà été mise à jour cette fois
pour ajouter les informations sur les
dernières crises il est encore une fois
une référence importante en économie
mais c'est surtout un classique pour les
universités américaines et pour le monde
de la finance il est même devenu un
manuel pour les investisseurs
particuliers qui suivent la stratégie
bailo sérail en france est achetée
bavent drôle parce que ces investisseurs
utilisent les exemples historiques
analysés par kindle berger afin
d'améliorer leur capacité à repérer les
points hauts et les points bas des
variations des actifs sur la forme c'est
l'histoire mondiale de la spéculation
financière n'est pas facile à lire il ya
certes des passages drôles sur les
fraudes les escroqueries mais
l'information aussi intéressante soit
elle est globalement difficile à digérer
non seulement il ya beaucoup de détails
mais l'auteur accumule les faits sans
vraiment faire l'effort à mes yeux de
les connecter les paragraphes et les
phrases sont vraiment long et beaucoup
paraissent parachuté comme s'il
s'agissait d'un copier coller de passage
de différents articles enfin le style
est impersonnelle bref ce livre est déjà
pénible à lire pour quelqu'un qui a de
bonnes bases en économie donc
probablement impossible à lire pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas ses bases qu'en
retenir sur le fond l'idée fondamentale
est liée à la dimension historique de
l'analyse de kindle berges le
comportement humain et les tendances de
marché ne change pas le long des siècles
par exemple le déroulement de la fameuse
crise des tulipes au nord des pays bas
au milieu du xviie siècle ressemble
beaucoup au déroulement des crises du
20e siècle
même s'il faudrait plutôt le dire dans
l'autre sens le prix du bulbes de
tulipes a très rapidement augmenter et
dans des proportions exceptionnelles
jusqu'à valoir autant qu'un champ de la
taille de plusieurs terrains de football
autre point commun entre cette crise et
les suivantes les hollandais investissez
leur argent durement gagné dans des
bulbes qui n'avait pas encore été
planter et cultiver ou récolter ils
n'achetaient donc qu'un morceau de
papier qui leur garantissait qu'il
recevrait est un bulbe au printemps
suivant
cet exemple illustre le cycle d'un
marché financier qu'on peut résumer avec
le titre anglais du livre la manie la
panique et le crash le point de départ
de la spéculation sur la tulipe a été de
l'engouement de l'élite hollandaise pour
sept plantes rares et exotiques le bulbe
est devenu un symbole de statut dès lors
les hollandais qui avaient les moyens
voulait en acheter et cela a créé une
classique boucle de rétroaction sur le
marché des tulipes les gens en demandent
des tulipes lé donc le prix augmente
l'augmentation fait penser aux
spéculateurs que le prix va continuer à
augmenter donc ils achètent des tulipes
ce qui fait encore augmenter le prix etc
c'est ainsi que se forment une bulle de
marché préalable à une crise financière
les investisseurs ou plutôt les
spéculateurs apprécié les actifs de
manière irrationnelle sans rapport à
leur valeur d'utilité c'est à dire leur
capacité à satisfaire des besoins ou des
désirs humains la boucle de rétroaction
à l'origine de la bulle de la tulipe
s'est arrêtée le jour où il n'y avait
plus d'argent à investir et à l'or s'est
enclenché une boucle inverse mais
l'effondrement du marché peut se
produire avant pour kindle berger cela
se produit en général lorsque au sommet
du cycle les initiés décide qu'il est
temps de sortir du marché cela entraîne
par mimétisme une ruée soudaine et
collective vers la sortie je me souviens
que galles bresse dit la même chose dans
la crise de 1929 ce sont une minorité
d'investisseur avisé des insiders dirait
ton dans la terminologie économique
moderne qui enclenche la baisse en
décidant de se retirer avant tout le
monde avec de substantiels profits la
rue et soudaine et collective vers la
sortie qui s'ensuit provoque une panique
générale qui fait baisser les prix la
panique se caractérise par le fait que
les consommateurs gèlent leurs actifs et
évite de dépenser pour assurer leur
sécurité financière celle inverse de ce
qui se passe lors de la manif où les
consommateurs délie les cordons de leur
bourse où on prête et on emprunte
volontiers pour le dire plus simplement
lors de la manie les acteurs prennent
des décisions inspirées par la confiance
lors de la panique et du crash ils
prennent des décisions inspirées par la
défiance mais dans les deux cas c'est
irrationnel
sur le plan théorique l'analyse de
kindle berger repose sur la loi de mines
ce qui du nom de l'économiste hyman
minsky cette loi dit que la stabilité
engendre l'instabilité voici
l'explication en période de croissance
les investisseurs recherchent un
surcroît de profits pour lequel ils
prennent des risques qui mettent en
péril la stabilité de tout le système
l'histoire de la spéculation financière
nous amène à nous poser une question
comment se fait-il que de nouvelles
crises surviennent alors même qu'on a
bien compris comment elle se déclenche
kindle berger pointe du doigt la
tendance des gens lors de la phase de
manille a oublié les précédents cycles
autrement dit ils oublient les leçons de
l'histoire en particulier la leçon selon
laquelle la bulle éclate toujours au
bout d'un certain temps mais c'est aussi
en partie la faute de l'environnement
économique qui incite les acteurs à
cultiver la cupidité au point de
renoncer à la lucidité la plus
élémentaire
16e référence la grande désillusion
joseph stiglitz ce livre est important
parce que c'est la critique de référence
de la mondialisation qui se définit
comme l'accélération des flux
internationaux de marchandises de
capitaux et de personnes il donne de
sérieux arguments aux altermondialistes
et l'éditeur américain joue d'ailleurs
sur cette fibre en ajoutant sur la
couverture de la dernière édition
l'antimondialisation a l'air de trump le
titre anglais dit plus clairement la
teneur du discours de stieglitz
globalisation nx10 quand est ce qu'on
peut traduire par la mondialisation et
les mécontentements qu'elle engendre le
titre qui a choisi l'éditeur français
quand même mieux et l'idée de ce titre
la grande désillusion c'est que la
mondialisation telle qu'elle fonctionne
telle qu'elle est gérée a grandement
déçu une particularité de ce livre c'est
que stiglitz et n'y va pas par quatre
chemins je le cite aujourd'hui la
mondialisation ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas pour les pauvres du monde ça
ne marche pas pour l'environnement ça ne
marche pas pour la stabilité de
l'économie mondiale il affirme que les
institutions internationales qui sont
censés gérer la mondialisation telle la
banque mondiale a par laquelle il est
passé de 1997 à fin 1999 quand il a
démissionné les institutions
internationales telles que la banque
mondiale privilégié en réalité l'intérêt
des états unis alors qu'elles ont pour
mission affichée de protéger et d'aider
les plus faibles stiglitz dénonce avec
virulence le dogmatisme et la
dangerosité économiques de ces
institutions et il n'y va vraiment pas
de main morte puisqu'ils donnent
carrément des noms et cela lui a été
reprochée
que dire de la grande désillusion sur la
forme c'est un livre plutôt facile à
lire le style de stiglitz est claire et
pédagogique
on sent qu'il veut qu'on le comprenne et
il n'y a pas trop de termes techniques
en outre le texte est subdivisé et grâce
à des sous titres et les paragraphes ne
sont pas interminable
après certains raisonnements économiques
théorique ne sont pas faciles à suivre
mais avec un petit peu d'effort des non
initiés sont capables d'aller au bout du
livre qu'est ce qui est essentiel sur le
fond maintenant la grande désillusion
dénonce tout d'abord un aveuglement
idéologique
stiglitz accuse le fmi et le département
du trésor américain d'avoir fondé leur
politique sur le dogme libéral de
l'infaillibilité du marché ils pointent
plus précisément du doigt ce qu'on
appelle le consensus de washington
cet ensemble de réformes recommandées
par le fmi et la banque mondiale est
imposée au pays requérant une assistance
financière issue de l'expertisé
prétendument scientifiques des
économistes de ces institutions le
consensus de washington repose en
réalité sur des théories remise en cause
depuis les années 1970 notamment par
l'économie de l'information dont
stiglitz est un des principaux
représentants
l'économie de l'information a montré que
le marché est rendue inefficace par
l'asymétrie d'information
c'est à dire par le fait que
l'information nécessaire à la prise de
décision est mal répartie entre les
agents or les institutions dénoncé par
stiglitz n'ont pas pris en compte ce
résultat bien au contraire elle
s'uniformise du point de vue idéologique
en promouvant le fantasme de la
perfection du marché et la peur de
l'inflation injustement assimilé à
l'hyperinflation
néanmoins dans les faits l'aveuglément
s'explique aussi en partie par l'
influence d'intérêts privés et du
carriérisme sur les décisions
économiques la deuxième chose
essentielle sur le fond c'est que comme
l'indiquent le titre anglais la gestion
de la mondialisation par les
institutions internationales est un
échec pour stiglitz les politiques
imposées par le fmi et la banque
mondiale ont fait beaucoup de tort
la libéralisation des mouvements de
capitaux et la financiarisation à
outrance ont même suscité des crises
économiques les mesures du fmi n'ont pas
seulement exacerbé la crise non stiglitz
elles ont aussi en partie provoqué sa
cause principale a probablement été la
libéralisation trop rapide des marchés
financiers
il poussa un cri de colère contre les
erreurs commises en russie et en asie
par le fmi et le département du trésor
américain dans le premier cas par
exemple ce n'est pas la rémanence du
soviétisme qui explique la crise des
années 1990 mais le triptyque
stabilisation libéralisation
privatisation de la thérapie de choc
voulue par boris eltsine dont a découlé
un fort accroissement de la pauvreté et
des inégalités
quant à la crise économique asiatique de
1997 elle a également résulter de
l'application scrupuleuse du consensus
de washington joseph stiglitz enfonce le
clou en montrant que des pays qui ont
refusé l'essai politique comme la chine
ou la malaisie aps ces pays s'en sont
mieux sorties ayant eu le courage de
résister aux pressions du trésor
américain et de ses alliés ces pays ont
introduit des contrôles de capitaux et
des changes qui les ont protégés de la
tempête financière
la dernière chose essentielle dans le
livre ce sont les solutions proposées
par stiglitz comme je voulais dire au
tout début bien qu'il passe pour un
opposant à la mondialisation il appelle
en fait de ses voeux une autre
mondialisation
il est persuadé que la mondialisation
peut enrichir les habitants les plus
pauvres de la planète si elle est gérée
correctement pour ce faire une
révolution idéologique est nécessaire
les institutions certains nationale doit
abandonner la fois en l'efficacité du
marché est dorénavant fonder leurs
interventions sur l'impératif de la
transparence de l'information
une fois l'idéologie corriger il faudra
alors plaide stiglitz des membres et les
institutions internationales qui rendent
à la mondialisation instable et
inégalitaire puis les remplacer par des
institutions régionales et impartiale
comme des fonds monétaire asiatique et
européen
17e référence freakonomics steven
levitte et stephen de bonheur cette
référence est importante parce qu'elle a
popularisé une branche particulière de
l'économie ce qu'on appelle la
microéconomie comme je l'expliqué dans
ma vidéo intitulée qu'est ce que
l'économie la différence entre ce qu'on
appelle la microéconomie d'une part et
la macroéconomie d'autre part la
différence tient à l'échelle danalyse le
préfixe micro vient du grec micro ce qui
signifie petit tandis que macro vient du
grec macro ce qui signifie grand la
microéconomie étudie donc le
comportement des acteurs individuels
tels que le consommateur ou l'entreprise
ainsi que leurs interactions l'idée
fondamentale de ce courant et que
l'individu cherche à maximiser son
utilité c'est à dire à satisfaire au
maximum et ses besoins dans un contexte
en fonction de ses propres ressources et
de l'action des autres acteurs les
micros économistes s'intéressent à tout
un tas de sujet de l'achat d'une voiture
d'occasion à la valeur des diplômes en
passant par les avantages du mariage
le livre freakonomics en particulier se
sert des outils intellectuels de la
microéconomie pour examiner des
situations économiques auxquelles les
économistes traditionnels ne
s'intéressaient pas par exemple celle
des agents immobiliers des vendeurs de
voitures des consommateurs de certains
services des profs ou encore des parents
c'est le sens du titre qui fusionne les
mots fric qui signifie insolite fou et
économique ce qui signifie sciences
économiques ce livre étudie des
problématiques de la vie quotidienne de
la tricherie à la criminalité en passant
par l'éducation des enfants et le sport
et parvenir à des conclusions qui
bouleverse les idées reçues
c'est cette originalité qui explique son
énorme succès dans les pays anglo-saxons
- en france il s'est vendu à plus de 4
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde et
il a été traduit en 35 langues à l'heure
où j'écris il est encore best seller sur
amazon us il passe d'ailleurs pour le
livre d'économie le plus lu aux états
unis
les profs le recommande souvent à leurs
élèves pour qu'ils aient une bonne image
de leur matière c'est d'ailleurs comme
ça que j'ai découvert il ya une dizaine
d'années sur recommandation d'un jeune
prof d'économie de mon école de commerce
l'édition américaine avec son sous titre
et rogue économistes explosive inside of
everything ce qui signifie un économiste
rebelles explore la face cachée de
toutes les choses avec ce sous titre
l'édition américaine nous vend l'idée
d'une nouvelle science qui permet de
découvrir la vérité cachée c'est sûr que
ça donne envie
ce qui est certain c'est que
freakonomics n'est pas difficile à lire
le style est moderne très simple et pour
tout dire journalistique et ce n'est pas
étonnant puisque le second auteur
stephen de bonheur et journalistes le
premier stephen lavit et prof d'économie
à l'université de chicago
journaliste de profession donc stephen
de bonheur c'est capté et conserver
l'attention du lecteur il s'adresse
directement à lui lui pose des questions
lui demande d'imaginer des situations le
propos est pédagogique les comportements
économiques sont analysés dans la langue
ordinaires et les concepts sont
illustrés par des exemples et puis le
caractère concret et originale des
problèmes soulevés est vraiment idéal
pour stimuler l'intérêt du lecteur il
n'a aucune excuse pour ne pas finir le
livre que retenir du fonds maintenant je
vais d'abord vous expliquer la
spécificité de la méthode économique des
auteurs puis je vous résume très
rapidement les analyses contenues dans
le livre pour faire simple l'originalité
de la démarche intellectuelle de
freakonomics repose sur le concept d'
incitation une incitation c'est ce qui
pousse quelqu'un à faire telle chose a
adopté tel comportement a éprouvés tels
sentiments par exemple un boulanger peut
inciter ses clients à acheter plus de
croissance en offrant le énième
croissant un prof peut inciter ses
élèves à apprendre la leçon en les
prévenant qu'il y aura peut-être un
devoir sur table c'est en incitant les
autres que les gens obtiennent ce qu'ils
veulent ou ce dont ils ont besoin pour
l'éviter et de bonheur les incitations
sont la clé du comportement humain c'est
avec cette clé de lecture qu'il combine
une étude rigoureuse parfois
statistiques des faits le bon sens et
l'abandon des préjugés pour parvenir à
des résultats étonnants l'application de
cette méthode leur a permis de
comprendre plusieurs choses le choix des
paramètres a mesuré est crucial pour
réfléchir à une question la sagesse
populaire a souvent tort les vraies
causes d'un phénomène sont parfois
éloignés mais enfin les experts
exploitent leur avantage je passe
maintenant aux analyses le concrètes qui
sont dans freakonomics
le premier chapitre parle justement des
incitations elle pousse parfois les gens
à tricher par exemple des enseignants
des écoles publiques de chicago ont
modifié les réponses sur les copies de
leurs élèves parce qu'ils risquaient
d'être licenciés ou pénalisées en cas de
mauvais résultat autre exemple au japon
la corruption et la pression sociale
incite les lutteurs de sumo a triché et
a raté certains matches importants
le deuxième chapitre fait un parallèle
entre le klu klux klan la société
secrète terroriste suprémacistes blanche
des états unis et les agents immobiliers
oui la comparaison aux sert à illustrer
le concept d'asymétrie d'information
depuis que stetson kennedy un homme qui
avait infiltré le ku klux klan dans les
années 1940 a publié une grande partie
des informations secrètes de la société
depuis lors les gens ne la craignent et
plus autant que lorsqu'il était dans
l'ignorance les agents immobiliers eux
aussi ont intérêt à maintenir leurs
clients dans l'ignorance afin de
réaliser la vente de manière à optimiser
leurs intérêts a eu par exemple à vendre
très rapidement même au détriment des
vendeurs pour passer à une autre affaire
de manière générale les experts ont
tendance à abuser de leur avantage mais
des facteurs tels qu'internet réduisent
cet avantage le troisième chapitre
explique pourquoi les trafiquants de
drogue ne sont pas aussi riches qu'on ne
le croit en réalité les gangs de
trafiquants ont une structure très
similaire à celle de beaucoup
d'entreprises avec un petit nombre de
personnes au sommet qui capte une
majorité du profit et des centaines de
personnes au bas de l'échelle qui s'en
sortent à peine les ressources se
répartissent comme très souvent
la loi de pareto ces gens qui sont en
bas de l'échelle reste dans le gang
parce qu'ils espèrent monter les
échelons tout comme les athlètes et les
artistes qui travaillent dur pour des
bénéfices très limité le titre du
quatrième chapitre et où sont passés
tous les criminels c'est ce chapitre qui
a fait scandale en mettant en évidence
un lien entre l'avortement et la
criminalité selon les vite la baisse de
la criminalité américaine au milieu des
années 1990 s'explique par la décision
de la cour suprême roversio wade de 1973
qui interdit aux états américains de
criminaliser l'avortement
cette décision a permis à de nombreuses
mères adolescentes pauvres et peu
instruites de ne pas mettre au monde des
enfants qui seraient probablement devenu
des criminels à l'âge adulte les
croyants ont accusé ce chapitre de
promouvoir l'avortement tandis que les
progressistes l'ont accusé de
stigmatiser les femmes des minorités
enfin les chapitres 5 et 6 parle de
l'éducation des enfants
lévitte et de bonheur explique que les
parents se focalise sur des détails
parce qu'ils confondent les causes et
les aspects de la réussite sociale il
accorde par exemple beaucoup
d'importance aux prénoms mais le choix
du prénom n'est que la manifestation
d'une situation préexistante
à la vérité on peut la plupart du temps
prédire la réussite sociale de l'enfant
avant même sa naissance car elle dépend
principalement du niveau de réussite
sociale des parents c'est à dire de la
combinaison de leur niveau d'éducation
et de leur niveau de revenu
18e référence le cygne noir nassim
nicholas taleb
cette référence est importante en
économie parce qu'elle a eu et a encore
une énorme influence sur les élites
économiques occidentales notamment anglo
saxonnes elle a changé la manière de
voir le monde de toute une génération
d'entrepreneurs du début du xxième
siècle en leur faisant comprendre que
tout l'enjeu pour eux est de prendre de
bonnes décisions en ignorant ou le cours
des choses les mènera jeff bezos a par
exemple utiliser des concepts de ce
livre pour élaborer la stratégie
d'amazon ou le cygne noir a également
fait fureur dans le monde de la finance
monde don via un taleb puisqu'il a
d'abord été trader pendant 20 ans à new
york et à londres où il a remporté
d'importants succès sur les marchés
avant de se consacrer à l'écriture
d'ailleurs j'ai découvert ce livre sur
les conseils d'un colocataire qui
faisait un stage dans une banque
d'affaires après le choix de cette
référence est discutable pour plusieurs
raisons certains diront que ce n'est pas
de l'économie mais de la philosophie ou
encore autre chose à la vérité c'est un
essai inclassable parce que taleb qui ne
pensent pas le plus grand bien de
l'académisme et des universitaires taleb
se fout des frontières entre les
disciplines intellectuelles
pour autant il applique son concept de
cygne noir surtout à l'économie et à la
finance certains diront justement que le
cygne noir n'est pas un travail
académique seulement les meilleures
références celle qui nous aide à
comprendre le monde ne sont pas
forcément académique bref il y avait
certes des raisons valables de ne pas
inclure cette référence dans ma liste
mais il ya aussi de sérieux arguments
pour le faire
sur la forme c'est vrai qu'on est très
loin de l'académisme taleb se définit
lui-même comme un flâneur c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui préfère les promenades
tranquilles à un itinéraire détaillé et
qui révise son programme au fur et à
mesure qu'ils découvrent de nouvelles
informations sur son chemin le cygne
noir et rédigé selon cet esprit il n'y a
pas vraiment de cohérence d'ensemble
l'auteur nous mène d'un sujet à l'autre
sur le ton de la conversation certains
lecteurs disent que c'est facile à lire
parce que le propos est original
provocateur drôle est que taleb raconte
des histoires d'autres n'arrivent pas à
aller au bout à cause des concepts
mathématiques des références culturelles
érudite et de la tendance de taleb avoir
des idiots partout et à les dénoncer
d'une manière prétentieuse pour ma part
j'avais été conquis par la grande
originalité du propos
maintenant quelles sont les idées
essentielles de ce livre l'idée
fondamentale c'est la fragilité de notre
connaissance pour le dire très
simplement dans plein de situations nous
croyons savoir nous croyons comprendre
ce qui se passe mais il n'en est rien
taleb utilise la métaphore du cygne noir
en référence aux préjugés scientifique
antérieure à la découverte de l'autre
selon lequel tous les signes étaient
blancs cet exemple montre que d'un point
de vue logique un seul et unique contre
exemple suffit à invalider n'importe
quelle théorie mais taleb donne au
concept de cygne noir un sens précis
c'est un événement imprévisible de
grande ampleur et à propos duquel les
hommes élabore des explications après
coup pour se donner l'illusion qu'ils
auraient pu le prévoir cygne noir est
devenu une expression commune notamment
dans le monde anglo saxon utilisée par
les journalistes les écrivains les
intellectuels et plus globalement toutes
les personnes qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre répondre à notre besoin de
comprendre la réalité c'est probablement
son expérience de traders qui a inspiré
à taleb ce concept en effet il a fait
fortune grâce à ses positions
financières hétérodoxes lors du crash de
1987 et de la crise de 2007 un ami qui a
travaillé avec lui il m'a expliqué que
sa stratégie consiste à perdre un petit
peu d'argent la majeure partie du temps
et à réaliser des profits phénoménaux
lors des crises financières lesquels
surviennent avec une violence rare après
un aveuglement général
la théorie du cygne noir met ainsi en
évidence le fait que les acteurs
financiers ont fortement tendance à
sous-estimer à la fois la probabilité
est l'impact des événements rares
cependant il existe des signes noirs en
dehors de la sphère économique le succès
des réseaux sociaux les attentats la
diffusion des religions et de manière
plus générale les inventions pour la
plupart année par sérendipité c'est à
dire en exploitant des résultats obtenus
par hasard tous ces événements sont des
cygnes noirs une autre idée essentielle
du livre c'est le désordre fondamental
de la réalité taleb affirme qu'à
l'instar des marchés financiers la
réalité est formé de longues périodes
calmes prévisible c'est continue
entrecoupées par des événements brut aux
imprévus et doté d'une très forte
rémanence ce qui signifie que leurs
effets perdurent bien après la
disparition de leur cause les cygnes
noirs sont très rares mais ils sont les
événements qui altèrent fondamentalement
la réalité
taleb distingue plus précisément deux
dimensions de la réalité au sein de ce
qu'il appelle le medio christan la
moyenne est essentielle si bien qu'un
seul individu n'a quasiment pas d'impact
comme dans les statistiques du poids de
la taille ou de l'âge au sein de ce
qu'il appelle l'extrémiste ans en
revanche les valeurs extrêmes sont
prépondérantes comme c'est le cas sur
les marchés du livre et du cinéma ou une
extrême minorité de produits rafle la
quasi totalité des revenus vous l'avez
compris c'est dans cette seconde
dimension de la réalité l'extrémiste ans
que survienne et les cygnes noirs
enfin la dernière idée essentielle du
livre c'est l'incompétence intellectuels
des hommes ils surestiment fortement
leurs capacités à interpréter le réel et
partant à anticiper les événements
futurs et à en maîtriser les risques en
pratique même les individus prétendant
faire oeuvre de science tout
particulièrement les économistes même
ces individus applique à la réalité des
méthodes d'analysé beaucoup trop
simpliste alors même que les facteurs
déterminants des phénomènes leur échappe
complètement leur biais cognitifs
principal est la convention de
continuité selon laquelle l'étude du
passé permettrait de dessiner l'avenir
or cette convention est invalidée par
l'imprévisibilité fondamental de la
réalité taleb et illustre cette erreur à
l'aide de l'allégorie de la dinde je le
cite chaque apport de nourriture va la
renforcer dans sa croyance que la règle
générale de la vie et d'être nourris
quotidiennement par de sympathiques
membres de la race humaine soucieux de
ses intérêts comme le disent les hommes
politiques le mercredi après midi
précédant noël quelque chose d'inattendu
va arriver à la dinde qui va l'amener à
réviser ses croyances cette allégorie
montre que la méthode de l'induction qui
consiste à raisonner du particulier vers
le général n'est pas fiable en effet
recensé tous les cygnes blancs ne
permettra jamais d'avoir la certitude
qu'il n'existe aucun signe noir
19e reference system un système 2 les
deux vitesse de la pensée daniel
kahneman ce livre est important parce
que c'est la référence d'un des
chantiers actuels de la réflexion
économique la dimension psychologique
des interactions économiques certains
disent que c'est la bible des pieds et
cognitif c'est à dire des mécanismes de
pensée qui conditionne notre jugement et
nous empêche parfois de prendre la
meilleure décision mais cela dépend du
contexte le livre à près de 22000 note
sur amazon us c'est vous dire à
l'ampleur de sa popularité
daniel kahneman est un psychologue
israélien avec une formation en maths ce
qui ne l'a pas empêché de décrocher le
prix nobel d'économie en 2002 pour ces
travaux où il applique la psychologie à
la finance à l'époque il déclare même
n'avoir jamais suivi un seul cours
d'économie
ce qui excite un peu plus la jalousie
des économiste de formation qui non
seulement aucun émane n est pas
économiste il est officiellement preuve
de psychologie et d'affaires publiques à
la prestigieuse université américaine de
princeton à une heure de voiture de new
york non seulement il n'est pas
économiste mais ces idées dépassait
largement le champ de l'économie les
travaux sur le jugement et la prise de
décisions qu'il a menée depuis les
années 1970 en collaboration avec amos
faire ce qui est un autre psychologue
israélien mort en 1996 ces travaux ont
eu une grande influence dans de nombreux
domaines dont notamment la médecine et
la politique c'est sûr que si on
découvre comment l'esprit humain
fonctionne ça ne va pas servir
uniquement en économie les travaux de
cannes et man ont également inspiré
certains des essayistes les plus lus au
monde comme le linguiste steven pinker
où le journaliste malcolm gladwell sur
la forme system un système de les deux
vitesse de la pensée ne plaira pas à
tout le monde d'un côté et ce livre a
pour lui le fait que son propos est
intéressant original et même fascinant
dans la mesure où on a l'impression
qu'on va découvrir les secrets de la
pensée autre point positif le style est
d'une simplicité moderne et kahneman
écrit sur le mode de la conversation de
l'autre côté cependant la lecture est
quand même un peu indigeste kahneman
mentionne et des cris trop d'études
scientifiques et il le fait avec du
vocabulaire technique pour couronner le
tout il y en a quand même pour près de
600 pages et donc il ne faut pas être
pressé qu'est ce qui est essentiel sur
le fond maintenant l'idée fondamentale
et comme l'indiquent le titre qu'il
existe deux vitesses de fonctionnement
du cerveau que kaneman nomme système 1
et systèmes de le système 1 tout d'abord
fonctionne de manière automatique et
inconsciente c'est notre cerveau
intuitif qui réagit automatiquement
inconsciemment et très rapidement à
notre environnement il le fait en nous
fournissant des informations imparfaite
voire illusoire ce qui rend possible la
manipulation psychologique
nous utilisons par exemple ce système un
pour lire des phrases facile résoudre
des problèmes mathématiques simples ou
percevoir des objets qui entrent dans
une catégorie à l'évidence nous n'avons
pas intérêt à nous fier à ce système il
fonctionne en effet par des biais de
telle sorte qu'il nous entraîne à
prendre de mauvaises décisions par
exemple lorsque nous lisons une phrase
particulièrement compliquée qui demande
un effort de réflexion supplémentaire le
système 1 nous pousse à substituer au
véritable sens de cette phrase compliqué
un sens plus facile le système 1
prédomine naturellement c'est pourquoi
notre jugement est conditionné par des
biais cognitifs la deuxième partie du
livre répertorie les grands biais
cognitifs kaneman évoque par exemple
l'ancrage le fait que les informations
reçues en premier se fixe solidement tel
langres d'un bateau dans l'esprit humain
au point que nous négligeons les
informations que nous découvrons
ultérieurement pour le dire plus
simplement nous accordons trop
d'importance à la première impression
maintenant qu'est-ce que le système 2
c'est notre cerveau rationnel il s'agit
d'une mécanique puissante mais lente au
démarrage contrairement au système
inquisitoire à la vitesse de l'éclair
nous utilisons le système 2 pour mener
des raisonnements et résoudre des
problèmes difficiles ce mode de pensée
nous permet également de nous concentrer
sur un sujet étant donné que le système
2 coûte plus d'efforts et qu'il est dans
la nature humaine d'éviter les efforts
nous dépendons du système 1
kaneman analyse ensuite d'autres
questions à travers le prisme de
l'opposition entre le système 1 et le
système de l'excès de confiance en soi
notre difficulté à interpréter les
statistiques la mesure du bien-être en
conclusion l'apport fondamental de cette
référence en économie c'est qu'elle
réfute scientifiquement est
expérimentalement le postulat de la
théorie classique selon lequel l'acteur
économique prend des décisions
rationnelles
la plupart de ces décisions sont en
réalité déterminé par le système
1/20 référence le capital au 21ème
siècle thomas piketty ce livre est
important en économie parce que c'est la
critique de référence du capitalisme
actuel le titre fait bien sûr référence
au capital de marx mais le propos de
thomas piketty n'est pas anti
capitaliste l'économiste français
dénonce lui aussi les inégalités mais il
ne prêche pas pour le communisme c'est à
dire la disparition de la propriété
privée il appelle de ses voeux une
action politique forte en faveur de la
réduction des inégalités
le capital au 21ème siècle est également
incontournable parce que c'est
certainement à l'heure où je vous parle
en octobre 2021 le livre d'économie le
plus influent au 21e siècle il s'en est
vendu des millions d'exemplaires en
quelques années il a notamment fait un
tabac aux états unis il a été traduit en
40 langues et ce succès a fait de thomas
piketty la rockstar de l'économie selon
le 'financial times' désormais invités à
donner des conférences un peu partout
les conclusions du livre ont transformé
le débat sur la richesse et les
inégalités et définit les chantiers de
réflexion de l'avenir proche sur la
forme thomas piketty s'exprime avec une
simplicité moderne il évite la plupart
du temps le vocabulaire technique ne
fait pas étalage de son érudition
dynamise le propos avec des questions et
structurer efficacement le texte en
paragraphes je trouve qu'il ya un
véritable effort de pédagogie pour
s'adresser au grand public seulement la
difficulté à lire le capital au 21ème
siècle ne vient pas de là c'est trop
long et aussi probablement trop
rébarbatif pour le lecteur qui souhaite
développer sa culture économique sans
consacrer des semaines voire des mois à
un seul livre maintenant quelles sont
les idées essentielles de ce livre la
thèse de piketty c'est que le
capitalisme non régulés génère de
grandes inégalités ce qui est un
problème crucial pour l'harmonie sociale
il s'appuie sur l'énorme travail
d'analyste de statistiques de son équipe
pour mettre en lumière la dynamique de
l'évolution de la richesse depuis les
200 dernières années il dit dans
l'introduction que le débat sur les
inégalités a besoin de fait s est vrai
que la dimension factuelle du livret est
impressionnante
les données révèlent tout d'abord que
les inégalités ont explosé dans les
décennies récentes en effet les
inégalités du début de notre siècle sont
comparables à celles du 19e siècle quand
tu écrivais marx et du début du 20e
siècle dans les états unis du début du
xxième siècle par exemple la part de la
richesse globale détenus par les
privilégiés à grosso modo était
multiplié par deux depuis la fin des
trente glorieuses
la progression est moins spectaculaire
en europe cela dépend aussi des pays
mais la dynamique est là même les deux
guerres mondiales avaient certes en
partie annulée le processus de
concentration de la richesse en
annihilant les grands patrimoines en
europe mais le processus a repris son
cours normal dans les années 1970
piketty affirme que ces données mettent
en évidence une mécanique naturel de
l'inégalité cette mécanique et que les
revenus du capital progressent plus vite
que la croissance économique dont
dépendent notamment les salaires cela
signifie concrètement que les
privilégiés qui tire des revenus de leur
richesse c'est la définition du capital
une richesse destinés non pas à la
consommation immédiate mais a rapporté
des revenus à son propriétaire la
mécanique naturel de l'inégalité
signifie concrètement que les revenus
des privilégié les détenteurs du capital
croissent plus vite que les revenus de
la masse des gens qui gagnent leur vie
en travaillant et plus les capitalistes
sont riches plus la différence de
vitesse est importante la fiscalité
avait certes permis de contenir cette
mécanique naturel de l'inégalité le
siècle dernier notamment grâce à la
progressivité de l'impôt sur le revenu
seulement les conditions sont désormais
réunies qui libère deux nouveau la
mécanique naturel de l'inégalité la
croissance et donc la vitesse de
progression des salaires ralenti et dans
le même temps la rentabilité du capital
s'améliore notamment pour les plus
riches une autre idée essentielle du
livre et les avantages que représente
l'héritage au 21ème siècle très
concrètement une personne qui part de
rien doit travailler de plus en plus
longtemps pour épargner à ces et espérer
se constituer un patrimoine en général à
acquérir son logement cette personne est
de plus en plus désavantagés par rapport
à celle qui hérite un capital de leur
famille et qui acquièrent leur logement
plus facilement cette inégalité entre
ceux qui héritent et ceux qui n'héritent
pas nourri un sentiment de déclassement
à l'échelle des générations elle inspire
également à piketty une belle formule le
passé dévore l'avenir quelle est sa
solution pour réduire les inégalités
accroître la pression fiscale sur les
grandes fortunes en pratique piketty
imagine un genre dit sf au niveau
mondial ou au moins européen pour
empêcher l'exil des riches dans le
détail cet impôt tiendrez compte de la
valeur de marché de l'ensemble des
actifs financiers professionnels et
c'est immobilier nette de dettes pour
finir sachez que si le capital au 21e
siècle a reçu beaucoup d'éloges il a
aussi été très critiqué mais c'est
naturel étant donné le succès du livre
par exemple nassim nicholas taleb
l'auteur du cygne noir dont je vous ai
parlé il ya une dizaine de minutes
taleb refuse les conclusions de piquer
type parce qu'elles portent
exclusivement sur les inégalités
statique c'est à dire qu'elles ne
prennent pas en compte les changements
de position dans la hiérarchie
économique les inégalités dit dynamique
aux yeux de taleb l'inégalité n'est pas
un problème pour l'harmonie sociale si
com aux etats-unis le bénéficiaire
risque de tout perdre c'est à dire si
dans la société des gens s'enrichissent
et d'autres s'appauvrissent en
permanence en revanche les inégalités
sont un problème pour l'harmonie sociale
si les positions ne changent pas si
comme en france l'état fige la
hiérarchie économique
taleb vous appliquez ti comme un
mandarin jaloux des riches et qui
manifeste une solidarité théorique pour
consolider ses privilèges
enfin sachez également que le travail
statistique sur lequel s appuie le
propos du capital au 21e siècle a été
remis en cause dans un livre publié deux
ans plus tard en typique et y vivent le
capital au 21ème siècle une vingtaine
d'économistes accusent piketty de
manipuler les données pour qu'elle
soutienne sa thèse je ne vais pas entrer
dans le détail mais ils lui reprochent
le fait que ces méthodes de collecte des
données ne soient pas fiable alors la
vidéo vous a plu j'espère que oui si
vous ne l'avez pas fait je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez découvrir les cinq
secrets pour vous cultivez 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez moi
faites le et vous me remercierez
[Musique]